[Music]
you just showed up like you might need
some practice uh you going down for the
count it's going down tonight i do it
all for my family you do it all for the
likes i hit that bell and i'm ready to
fight turn me up turn me up turn me up
they want the belt they don't work and
know don't mess around
[Music]
[Applause]
his flight delayed and he'll be here in
20 minutes is that right team about 20
minutes so he's landed then he's landing
or he's landing in 20 minutes nope he
should be in there it doesn't matter you
know what it doesn't matter he'll be
here
all right you're asking me details yeah
here's my question now uh to my left is
uh the very funny the very talented you
know him from the king the sting and the
wing
and the sing
it's air griffin everybody yeah my first
time i'm getting this is my oh it is
yeah how cool ufc
i just watched my first fight the other
day was that patty fight oh yeah that
was my first one and i was like oh wow i
started starting to understand yeah yeah
he's your favorite fighter now yeah yeah
yeah so that's great there you go that's
great it's a good one to like you get to
me when you meet you say like ever since
i first started watching fighting yeah
you're the one that got me into the
sport i was like bro
yeah
so we had details man details and then
then you know the guy the man sitting
across from me he's dressed like a
hypeboy priest it is the one the only
you don't miss the wing
it's
weighing in at 196. no matter what his
weight is always this is the same no
matter what he can work out hard his
weight will be the same the same he
could eat a lot his his weight will
still be the same no matter what it's
either fat or muscle whatever it is he's
always
196.
he's an ectomorph yeah i wish i could
say that
yeah me too bro i eat too much rice and
your boy balloons up i'll be 280 if i
eat too much rice i'll be 196.
i knew that guy was going to win that
guy's going to win you're making fun of
him though
we weren't live and you were judging a
book by its cover i was i really that's
something i'm learning about this you
can't do in the youtube you can't judge
a book by itself no way yeah yeah wait
hold on a second you already have
somebody that you think's gonna win
you're gonna say well
i was watching it was the prelims and
they showed uh mourinho
though that dude can fight but i saw a
couple of swings and i was like oh this
guy's sneaky and then i i knew he was
going to win the fight because the other
guy
wasn't countering the way he should yeah
these are good
chris
that's all you need though right
you kind of skip
past i asked why you're dressed in a
mock turtleneck like an offensive
coordinator from cincinnati bangladesh
i'm a priest i'll tell you what it is
look a monk i'm always you know me i'm
always pushing the boundaries of fashion
right sure i mean i'm dressed like
sylvester stallone from over the top so
that's fine
what a great move
is it great i don't know i also get
tango in cash
that movie that's why we're buddies
now over the top i was maybe bad that
was i don't remember yeah yeah
but i'm pushing the boundaries of
fashion dude i got this [ __ ] it's
actually just it's like got a nice neck
dude i put it on you know what this is
this is the gap balenciaga he's easy i
know and i got it and i i i got like an
airbender do you know what i do
you know what i do though is like i'll
get the emails for all the shits and
then i and i by the time i click on them
they're sold everything's sold out done
right dude i got the email i clicked on
it and there was i was like oh [ __ ] so i
just got it
and and they're like you i thought they
would be like 500 or not 120 so i got
[ __ ] two and uh that would be cool
you're bored you would have got one 500
but two
no i probably wouldn't have got one if
it was 500. it's that sense of demand
the same thing like if i know even if a
shoe or whatever it is our shirt if i
don't like you i'm like oh i know it's
about i know if i don't buy it now it's
gone yeah i'm like [ __ ] i do but do
you stand in line like no way no
dude but if there were people standing
in line for this and like there were
there's i i got you can get more you can
get them now i think still but but uh i
was gonna say [ __ ] oh this is a [ __ ]
guess what size it is
that's a medium double xl this is a
small
and that's why i [ __ ] with balanciaga
because i walked in there i
i got to start wearing this stuff yes
that's why i go there i want to be like
i'm i'm in the petite section
i don't know that no that's exactly what
i tell you chris
when i went in the store
bro i made sure they knew this i went i
left i went i'm going to leave with my
mediums have a good day yeah i like that
i wear a medium that's why i stopped at
dxl yeah watch like a gsm
because they have like they have like
you know they have like
at the excel store so i come in and go
where's the small area
i'll say something embarrassing i used
to have an endorsement deal with uh big
and tall oh really that's not
embarrassing it is your biggest
big and thank you no hold on hold on i'm
not that big and tall i couldn't wear
anything so they'd be like can you just
give me your regular clothes and say oh
really oh no
because i couldn't wear their clothes
but they'd be like do you mind if we put
you in something like sure and it'd look
like a nightgown yeah
this is an
eight-time x what are we doing [ __ ]
steve harvey and kings that's exactly
what it was i looked so baggy ridiculous
yeah yeah but they have like i just it's
all about the it's all about the shape
so of course when i go get a regular 2xl
at a place yeah from here to here i'm
good right right right but what happens
is it doesn't i don't know if i'm shaped
like an ostrich you know what i mean
well this will work that'll work
but my thing with uh balenciaga
a little out of shape now right yeah so
he likes it very long here and then big
in the box i like that though
i like it longer than the body all my
stuff is long i like it long and tight
but that's have daddy 2 xlt that's what
i'm saying two xlt tall that's why i go
to that that's why i stopped by yeah
yeah i get what you're saying though i
get what you're saying but my shoulders
go crazy so when i wear it like [ __ ]
they you know what i mean it like
you look at me and it's like you know
it's like a mysterious note but how big
is he and well he came out it's an
offensive coordinator for the baltimore
ravens
you know what i really want to first of
all i want to thank the fans i want to
thank god and uh we came out and we did
our thing and they got the best of us
so you lost yeah
[Laughter]
you could have said anything you could
have won a championship you could go we
honestly lost by a lot i mean really
really sorry uh we lost by 25 points
just assume you're the worst team from
jump in the beginning they scored and uh
hopefully next year we get a win
never won a game
so this is at the american airlines
dallas dallas texas is it that that's
hilarious you know why
august 26 i'll be in dallas no i know
but it's hilarious are you playing in
the same no i don't know it's it's it
might be as big but that's what i heard
i am playing uh the grand prairie uh at
this texas trust cu cu trust center or
whatever the [ __ ] it's called yeah that
sounds weird whatever it is it does
sound weird but that's why b so
chrisley.com for tickets i'll be in
dallas and wichita wichita okay
questions about the fight now i got a
question do these girls know each other
uh they're friends
friends
no no they're not friends competitors
and then they were coaches on the
ultimate fighter that nobody watches
anymore i was on season 10 but you see
all the anyways so i'll be in baltimore
that's so interesting yeah it's well
yeah see i said the ravens that's a
callback
i said ravens to full circle i'm in
baltimore next thursday friday saturday
i like that i like sir no i like scott i
like john anik okay do you know john i
don't know on
you know we follow each other and
[ __ ] comment but he's a twin oh he
does oh he's always weirds me out twins
are weird bro i watch harry potter and
like the twins every time they come on
like you love harry potter yeah i'm not
i'm like it's [ __ ] weird it takes me
out they're the weirdest part of it and
they got well
first of all first of all oh boy
to me
twins
and redheads yeah don't trust them
together
just redheads in general
redheads period and twins period well
they're both that's the devil right
they're both yeah that's the devil
if you're a twin and redhead yeah evil
right well they're well they're good in
uh harry potter right yeah yeah i've
never seen harry potter um what you have
children you've never seen harry potter
26 dude
so because we
we have count we didn't watch it yeah
kristin loves harry potter thank you
yeah he loves it yeah i'm just not into
those movies yeah you're not into fun
things no i lied into fun things
things have to be like you know you know
what i'm into huh bollywood what have
you seen a bollywood movie okay i'm done
with you no dude yeah i'm out too
hey hold on oh you're you're injured oh
yes probably 100 percent check please
check please
julia's friendship check please smile
never not smiling dude yeah it's like
the story is going on and for no reason
they start doing it
musicals i cannot wait to talk about
this on my podcast because i'll do 20
minutes on dancing in bollywood and i
won't do it here i'll spare you guys but
did you like aladdin with will smith the
same [ __ ] no no i didn't see it though
dude no they're dancing i don't know
honestly dude they did have a bollywood
movie that's what i'm saying travis you
don't know what bollywood is though bro
there's and they're so famous out there
i watch that rr movie on netflix holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] what is it it's called rrr
i think i'm a seizure
explorer
dude
this is crazy to see uh this is brutal
happen really honestly what do you mean
women fighting well just period but then
also like i know because like these
women are legit dude like they [ __ ]
these two tonight so just so you guys
know i know you guys are like the big
cfc heads she's the greatest female
fighter of all time really really most
would regard her as the number one of
all time
yeah yes of course she's phenomenal ow
she's a champion at 45.
35.
she went like this she was like okay
she she's the one who ended uh
ronda's career she
just showed that right yeah yeah she
knocked out uh oh she broke up she
knocked out uh cyborg right there so
cyborg is regarded as the number one of
all time then she destroyed her god damn
she hits like a mack truck son oh i
don't like oh that little smile she had
on her face but the problem is the
problem is is uh now watch her daughter
sue julian pendleton left her dodge
behind her like this
that dawn one on the left's daughter
yeah her daughter's behind her she
doesn't know this and she's like fisted
up like ready to find me so cute
but uh
penny is a beast yeah so and she's still
she's a i think the third biggest
underdog when she beat uh amanda nunes
and then now she's also like that look
at that if that's us right there those
three what are they saying like you know
we should you know them the three of
them yeah the three of them that's yeah
that's basically the fight version of
king is sticking a wing
you're the guy on the right
so this is bram moreno he's the first
mexican-born champion they fight at 125.
i'll tell you they celebrate the [ __ ]
out of him in mexico yeah more boxing
but they're getting onboard because of
him but they have yaya rodriguez and
obviously canelo's by far the biggest oh
wow that guy couldn't even he couldn't
even tap out he was already passed out
yeah but um where i was going oh before
you came on chris before we went live i
was explaining to eric
when you watch the a lot of people don't
it's just it's just an arrogance thing a
lot of people don't respect the guys
because they're 125 pounds so if you're
sitting on a couch and you've never been
in a gym you're like 125 pounds
no you won't be
in like i'd say 170 welterweight to
heavyweight up if you're a bigger dude
in america or you know even in europe
you're in baseball football basketball
soccer the real athletes aren't you
don't want to fight ufc it's a nightmare
there's no guaranteed money there's no
direct way to get there so the smaller
guys don't have they can't like if
you're 125 pounds what sport you can
play in america what do you do
so so the pool the sample size is so
much bigger for the smaller guys
so the talent level to get to the to
where they're at yeah they're good at
everything how do you know that how do
you know that just from being in the ufc
and like experiencing it or what
what do you mean well like how did you
figure out that like that's a very like
interesting thing that i don't that i
would never think of yeah
just being around it like the experience
and then the smaller guys like i'd see a
smaller guy who's nowhere near the ufc
like he's you know he's been fighting
for a
number of years and you're like dude
you're good at every you're black on
everything you're like yeah i know and
he's just too tough to get out wow dude
but it was a bigger guy like when i was
a heavyweight i had yeah because they're
gonna play [ __ ] football you're
correct right and i came from football
and they're like we're all set on slow
white guys i'm gonna take my [ __ ]
to the ufc and then within four years
i'm ranking the top ten like that
wouldn't happen at all oh my god
that's who i wanted to see derek i see
these guys bodies and i'm like should i
be fighting the ufc you know what i mean
well then you've got to look at this guy
though yeah jesus christ but not but i
don't believe this anymore this is all
smoke and mirrors now what do you mean
when i now i know oh because yeah you
could yeah
because one of the greatest of all time
fedor had his body he looked like homer
sims a russian homer simpson uh kane
velazquez had no chest it was like
they're like hey you want to try the
bench he's like nah i don't like that
stuff you know well what is that what is
the actual benefit though of uh and it
may sound like a silly question
what is the benefit is there a a huge
benefit for being say
in like having a ripped physique when it
comes to fighting
does it help or is there any kind of
downside there's a downside because the
guys who are really muscle bound it
requires more oxygen so they they gas
out faster so the greatest of all time
like stipe verdum uh cane velazquez they
weren't ripped they had a little bit of
fat you need fat for the fuel you
actually have better endurance yeah
steeper i got a lot of fuel yeah i
watched a clip on him of like a [ __ ]
highlight clip on him monster bad
[ __ ] yeah yep when he very first
came to uc he was my training partner in
denver i used to have wars i wish we had
it on film somebody does
yeah iphones weren't everywhere then you
know yeah don't have like that big ass
yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] one of these
i sent you in four years
yeah yeah
that's when that's when people were
seeing bigfoot yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah bigfoot going bigfoot
you got your your [ __ ] wife in the
back of the boom
i knew when i said that you weren't
going to laugh until a few seconds after
i said i'm going to do that
because i'm thinking about how you
created that scene in your head and i'm
saying you [ __ ] [ __ ] and then i
was like and then after i'm like i like
that
[Laughter]
what's calvin's thing like what's he
like uh boston's thing right now he
loves music videos like he loves dancing
it's great this crazy his favorite video
i mean his favorite video is journey the
original journey oh wow like he loves
that old school journey one and he'll
just start like he pretends he's on the
mic
very strange my my son likes uh
dinosaurs like just [ __ ] everything
to do with dinosaurs but like a certain
tv show or a movie uh so he oh peppa pig
loves peppa pig
jurassic park
well it's just violent right now the
first one i'm talking about the first
one it's pretty violent it's also a
little
but netflix has a cartoon on there of
drastic right my kids love really lovely
i love it
and it's more like upbeat like
action-packed gotcha oh that's cool yeah
like we went to go see super pets
uh that movie that came out he says
through the movie oh yeah how was that
bro my son
um
i fell asleep and chris said it got
better but um it's uh
uh he's he bro my son
is focused man
on everything too it's just
he'll see a new person at the wedding
yeah bro it's just yeah he was chill he
wasn't panicking right he'll sit through
the whole thing he said one thing
i can't bring my son yeah i know most
kids oh i brought him he has he doesn't
know the etiquette it's like you brought
a a dude from [ __ ] ireland who's
never been to a movie theater he was yup
mama more eminem it's like bro what are
you doing he's on the seat walking
grabbing people's popcorn like dude yeah
control first of all this is why
i don't go to movies before
5 p.m yeah yeah no i know because that's
where that should happen yeah yeah well
even also but i don't want to see like
if it's after five and i'm seeing some
fun movie at eight p.m yeah and your kid
is there well if there's a two-year-old
dude you don't have a problem oh i'd
like i'd be like what are you doing yeah
well but and you're in you're you're
seeing venom what are you doing dude
yeah whatever that oh yeah but also yeah
well if you're seeing venom yeah that's
[ __ ] i do my son the venom you did
how old what which which song last year
tiger he was six wow what's pj what's up
yeah but he like hates [ __ ] people no
it just shows
it just shows me it hit don't show any
blood nothing but also it was a lot to
be honest he had my nightmares yeah i
mean it's a scary [ __ ] thing i was
scared
mitchell carnage woody harrelson isn't
[ __ ] nuts yeah i'll tell you what
though fellas uh what's up everyone's
hairy here and my friends at manscape
they got an alert for you it's time to
take a little break here you asked for
it and my friends at manscape they
listened our friends manscape just
brought back the ultra smooth package
it's time to stop drop order this
premium shave kit everyone knows by now
that the lawnmower 4.0 is the best
electric shave for your balls but if
you're looking for a closer save i gotta
hurry this up it's my favorite fight in
the card anthony smith he's on food
truck on tuesday hopefully he doesn't
lose anyways but if you're looking for a
closer save to go bear down there then
the ultra smooth package is the perfect
set it's time to shave that bush of
yours and get right to the root with a
discount just for you fellas or ladies
you might have some hairy you know
titties or something get 20 percent off
and free shipping at manscape.com with
code cfc
we got you guys man with this ultra
smooth package bro from manscape you get
the crop exfoliator you get the crop gel
when it's time to shave you get that
lawnmower 4.0 daddy it shaves your nuts
without nicking them it's the best in
the business it's time to get up close
and personal with the best tools for the
job the ultra smooth package from
manscape get 20 off and free shipping
with the code cfc at manscape.com
there's 20 off and free shipping with
the code cfc manscape.com smooth out
your fellas with the relaunch ultra
smooth package from the fellas at
manscape your balls will thank you now
let's get back to the program
so this guy this guy is anthony smith he
is the best teeth in the ufc they're
veneers but his teeth are lit really yes
also he looks like a guy that would give
you a parking ticket
yeah he looks like a guy that would be
like sorry i i started writing already
no come on man it looks like an
accountant it started working out you
know what i mean yeah totally well also
well those glasses are coming off right
so he doesn't so they must he must have
his vis that's one thing his vision must
be really bad because if you have to
leave the glass on the walk to octagon
yeah right but also that doesn't look
though
no no no no i totally get it because i
can wear contacts and i don't sometimes
glasses is just part of your look
because it's a part of your face right
right he's probably worn glasses
you'd just think a fighter would be like
okay i'll put in contacts so i can just
fight you can't wear contacts
technically you can't no or get lasik i
had both and cheated the system you
can't
you can't wear contacts cause you punch
and either pop out so there's a lot of
fighters you see some fighters like
justin gates he squints oh [ __ ] bro i
couldn't fight yeah charles oliveira was
like but i couldn't fight yeah i feel
you put him in you yeah
yeah jesus christ
yeah yeah but they're also like you got
some thick ass glasses oh yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it looks really
good well you have contacts in right now
yeah yeah
bro you have money
i know i don't want lasiks hold on
hold on it's 2004 in russia it's also
not even that expensive but it's also
like
lasers in your eyes sounds crazy you got
lasik huh terrifying i'll be honest
terrifying i mean i got my my nose i was
terrified you know what the terrifying
part is they go as you're doing it when
they slit open the little slit with a
laser they go now you're gonna go blind
for 30 seconds to 60 seconds bro
that's right because you're thinking if
this goes wrong
this is the moment yeah yeah i'm and
this is i'm blind for the rest of my
life hold on hold on i brought my
favorite point
i'd start singing you know what i mean
that's yeah yeah oh no they give you a
basketball just squeeze he got it yeah
yeah yeah that's good
um a stress ball i need all the [ __ ]
adivan for real uh now the guy he's
fighting so he's he's the biggest uh
besides uh i think pena he might be well
he might be the biggest one is that guys
security so this guy's from dagestan
dick stains are taking over the ufc i
think it's an issue because a lot of
don't speak english and to market to
american fans ufc went we're just trying
to hit the international market cool
good luck compete with one championship
but anyway so he's fighting this guy
this guy's a [ __ ] monster from
dagestan and anthony smith is a veteran
and he's like back on the rise again
the glass guy yeah but he's also an
analyst for the ufc and he's [ __ ]
brilliant speaks really well here's
what's inside about him dropped out of
high school his senior year started
doing concrete and started fighting but
he's really smart really articulate well
spoken obviously high school didn't mean
[ __ ] but then
recently uh what made the past year chen
some dude he left his garage door open
some dude on meth breaks into his house
starts goes to his computer and starts
screaming he has kids three daughters he
wakes up in the middle of night he's
like what the [ __ ] happening it's
anthony smith yeah tough is it coming
he's bigger than me he's huge he is he
fights he's huge whoa so he beats the
[ __ ] out of this guy beats the [ __ ] him
but he goes tufts find my life for five
minutes i have to whip his ass he was
i'm throwing knees elbows choking them
punch them guys just want to go down
meth but also decorated high school
wrestler
whoa
like the guy was a badass
and just fell on hard times gone to meth
okay that should be a pay-per-view
so he goes uh so this is from anthony
smith quote uh no no no no normal human
is able to fight like that i by no means
the baddest i'm by no means the baddest
dude on the planet but he's a regular
joe had a hard time dealing with him and
he took everything that i get i gave him
every punch every knee every elbow he
died every single one of them and kept
fighting look at the thing under that at
one point smith said his mother-in-law
brought him a kitchen knife which he had
held to haberman who continued to fight
him that's beth baby
and the mother-in-law how about this as
he's getting arrested is this dude i
know kill him okay kill him i'll be like
hey dexter
and the mother-in-law's like yeah yeah
kill them anyways
how about how about oh my god these guys
are giants they're huge as the as the
criminals being walked out he says hey
man i'm sorry he does no no the criminal
that he beat the [ __ ] up as he's getting
walked down hand guards guys he looks
like that's what's impossible i am 80
pounds heavier than both of these guys
no hold on that's not nice no no so i
should be 206 no bro they at six three
no no they're not 205. they were two or
five yesterday right now they're
probably 2 30 2 25 still they cut to 205
wow
they they can't gain that much weight in
one day oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah one
day oh yeah yeah daddy 25 pounds water
weight oh yeah 20 pounds yeah oh yeah oh
yeah
that sounds crazy it does sound crazy
speaking of what were they why were they
checking him were they checking him for
weapons no they checked they check if
you have uh like uh extra vaseline on
your gloves or if you have it on your
body because you can get out of
submissions yeah yeah but you can get
vaseline on your face though yeah for
cuts okay yeah oh my god this guy broke
into this guy's house plus 450.
that is crazy
now he
now here's the this he's my bet i'm bet
on anthony smith not just because i'm a
fan of him he's coming on the show i
pick him because
his his uh experience he's fought
tougher guys and beat tougher guys so
you want him to win obviously
lionheart let's get it dana
only 99 this is such a gift
every ufc
every ufc field so thirsty to get on
there and he gets so mad when i call him
out i'm sorry theo
dana you're so good to us i would pay 9
000 for this card
do i need to uh tweet am i going to get
on
he's from
russia
we had it up here dagestanian monster
right here monster
maca chocolate this
this guy's here here here's the thing
fellas
i need anthony smith to get a win and
not get hurt okay that guy is like me in
30 years listen no no 30 years not 35
i mean
does
everybody what's up daddy what's up eric
welcome to ufc doug are you mad at that
hold on a second okay so
how do you
first time excellent quiet he's all
here we go oh man this is i never watch
a fight in a bit we need anthony smith
to win this and not get hurt i like this
guy i like i like how tatted up he is
well i like his stance right now like
he's got a firm solid
stance but he knows nothing other guys
these daggers dude they are taking over
combat sports why do you why do you say
that well because it's probably tough no
they grow up there but they grow they
have their sport of combat they grow a
chuff they grow up doing it oh it's like
it's like 300 yeah spartans and they
have beers
[Music]
come on anthony look how big they are
dude
so
go ahead chris no well i was just gonna
say there
that's heavyweights yeah no two or five
no okay what what's what's smith's uh uh
expertise what's he good at uh
everything i mean he's a black belt on
jujube he's not really like a jiu jitsu
like expert per se like he's a brawler
though i'm saying no he's honestly he's
been fighting so long he probably has 50
fights he has all his his main thing is
the experience and his fight iq he's a
really smart dude okay you hear how
smart he is when he speaks he's very
smart there's a reason why he's a
commentator
it's crazy that a guy can do
you just think of him as like brutes you
know
yeah when a guy has his personality and
like i mean even conor mcgregor you know
what i mean it's just like
so well [ __ ] yeah spoken yeah if only
one of them got out and like started
standing up like your whole podcast
network yeah
what i'm saying like you [ __ ] have
something about you that people want to
[ __ ] listen to it's like not many of
these guys do yeah i mean some of them
do you know
more and more is [ __ ] really like
when i sat down with him like oh jesus
but there's a lot of guys like that but
i do think it it's also a thing where
it's like
before it was even thought of like
you're like i'm a fighter this is it man
dude and now because and i'm saying it's
me there's people before me yeah but
there's a lot of people where you
they're seeing what i do or other guys
doing like oh [ __ ]
right right right right and a lot of
them have great personalities
grapple a lot heavy weights heavyweights
it just depends on the fighter oh
but but this uh
here's the other thing first
these type of stains come in i know i
struggle with english i know i know yeah
we know and i make money and i make
money speaking for a living yeah okay
i need to hire a russian translator and
help me get through this i know oh he
has a dream catcher on his back that's
lit i know that's a bit 90s but still
yeah
with uh matt here with a goat too though
is there a goat on there yeah there's a
goat head on the top of it yeah yeah
yeah
yeah do you guys know you michael bisman
yeah yeah so uh anthony smith does the
podcast with bisping and obviously
bismarck's another guy who's brilliant i
love business he speaks well yeah he's
great
oh he does it with bisping yeah yeah
this guy he he he looks like he's like
really trying like
which guy
smith
i feel like he has a healthy respect for
this guy's power correct you know i
could feel that he's like well this guy
he's kind of gauging like okay i don't
want to get i don't want to get tapped
but he's not this guy can crack
he knocks dudes out man yeah i could
tell he's like prepared for that
you can see how he's do because he's but
he's not he's not attacking yet though
he hasn't really engaged
each other they both have respect for
each other so no one's committing but
they're also feeling each other outside
imagine second third round you're gonna
get some more action but i feel like the
the russian guy is is moving a lot is
this going to tire him out at a
heavyweight you know he should be like
two oh she always moves like this okay
oh see he's coming oh [ __ ]
that combo was filthy yeah he didn't
really look like it connected too well
no connected enough he was born smith
was mad at himself about it you could
tell he was like damn it i got caught
smith fought uh glover texera and glover
went on to win the title this this big
brazilian glover
so bad he knocked his teeth out he's
going to go to the body and like second
round he goes back touring
my tooth fell out
you know yeah that's [ __ ] my tools
after that hit smith went he was
covering his face a lot look he's he's
more up here now on his defense i think
he got hurt i think i think i thought he
felt that one oh
he's trying to land something big though
yeah yes but this dagger standing dude
dude he started doing like greco or like
wrestling when he was like four
five yeah well what's his name [ __ ]
fights bears right when he was a kid
wow
wow come on it's hot
it's even hot you've never met before
you guys are buddies that mustache is
fantastic
i love that shirt are you fresh off the
set of yellow stuff dude let me tell you
something first of all i would be i have
a buddy that's a stunt guy and he was
like i just did a dope saying told me
all about it well give me spoilers out
nice you're a yellow it's pretty dope
i'm a yellow star i'm the biggest fan i
got to start the fight
i tried going what happened i had to get
on the ground the fight continues just
like he's not gonna let him get up no no
no no oh yeah you yeah this is what it's
like this is when it's like like a sixth
grade you know you know what i mean
get off of me
i think it's limping feeling each other
what's up how are you guys doing i mean
you guys are [ __ ]
sexy you look good you look good you
look good bro you look good you look
healthy as [ __ ]
no but you color and you got you have
been outside
i partnered up with a pool company so
i've been like
yeah we're like yes
i'm a sweat equity partner for this pool
company
uh back home and it's it's actually it's
really fun because it gave me something
to do again so you actually go out and
do the pool stuff yeah like i've been
like that's hilarious i oversee like all
this stuff like as far as like the digs
i got the excavators all this stuff
framing out shooting the gun it's a good
business we've talked about it before
yeah i'll tell you right now you come to
my house with that mustache like
everybody can come in not him
there's not around my kids no dice yeah
he's like i've been outside you know i'm
really working on my i'm not working on
my skin
that's exactly exactly what it is i
wouldn't want you yeah
please make sure the pool's good i
actually just popped off one of our one
of our homeowners because i felt she was
[ __ ] rude as [ __ ] and i was like dude
like i was saying something and she like
kind of suddenly stopped like no no no
no that's not what's going to go on like
hey that is not how you're going to talk
to me like i know you can't see me over
the phone you're right notice you want
to face
i mean it's like is it clear that it's
your company and people know like you
know
we fight for your pool no it's good
meat heads and pools
pools yeah that's it that's it
i love i love counter kicks man won't
you throw that [ __ ] and you mean it yeah
come down smith it'll be tough to get
him down though
yeah i don't think he's gonna get able
to get how's it how was the first round
it was they were always feeling each
other out yeah yeah but he caught him
will you give it to the dagger standing
just because at the end
is the whole nation just [ __ ]
gangsters can be i mean is that just
what happens this is what they do it's
like we grew up playing football they
grow up fighting fighting and wrestling
mustaches
and they're all full like if you can't
grow a real beard though you're not
diagnosed here's what's here's what's
amazing about daddy stands in the ufc
watch his hair it does not it's like a
helmet it's on a lego it does not move
the entire fight that's amazing it's
insane dude
you've been traveling your ass off yeah
i've been on tour a bunch back on tour
september gets really dicey i just chew
right into that microphone oh yeah oh
yeah
but so uh but your tan is [ __ ] you just
been i said i've been working on my skin
man hell yeah but it's cool like i
really actually i really do enjoy my job
i'm a hands-on guy right like i do a lot
of stuff like that always been building
stuff so i grew up framing and stuff
like that so this is something that i'm
i'm comfortable with and it gives me
something financially it's rewarding
like yeah and it gives me activity yeah
yeah you have something to do but i did
i did get a fight off her uh today to
consider i'll talk to you about it
afterwards yeah big name uh yeah well
yeah for sure they showed me a picture
uh because i know fedor says he wants
that fight back i know he does that
would be really exciting
no i can't wait now i don't want to wait
till the show is over
would you do it
uh if the money's right they didn't they
didn't show you that no they they tried
that they tried to play like oh well
what kind of what kind of money would
you like to talk about like well how
about you tell me what numbers you guys
are talking about first and then we can
talk about yeah i want you won't you
won't you throw a number out let's see
if it what's my beat let's see if we go
baby let's see i mean let's see how long
would it take you to get in fighting
shape it'll take me a little bit because
i'm fat right now i'm living a good
dream too man like i listen first of all
dude you're a [ __ ] legend no no no no
let me stop meet you let me stop you
right here
you're not fat okay
let me stop you there's levels yeah
there's levels in the game
yesterday um i i directed my two
youngest children to uh to cut to grab
biscuits like grands biscuits you know
to uh from the store so two like eight
packs or something like that cut them in
quarters then take reese's pieces uh i
know i'm sorry reese's peanut butter
cups holy [ __ ] he's getting mauled [ __ ]
now we're talking oh he's on food truck
on tuesday yeah is he rude yeah
oh oh you better get up buddy slide get
out of there
[Music]
then roll it then put in the bun pan and
then make it oh he got stopped dude he
stopped him
i mean dude was kind of an [ __ ] i
don't think it might have been a little
early but that
i don't know he was [ __ ] him up this
guy's a monster yeah but that guy how
are you look at his hair how come almost
all day look like abraham lincoln yeah
it's like it's like it's like the only
bit see i'm on your way dude
they have the same beard they have the
exact same beard same here
babe takes his hat off same [ __ ] sweaty
so you don't think they should have
stopped that no i don't think so
they could have gone a little especially
uh if he got up to the wall might have
been a toy difference you also got to
know who's in the octagon like if that's
a young kid all right stop it but
anthony smith as tough as they come 50
fights let it go been in the game a long
long time
they're gonna light this guy up now
they're gonna light him up uh probably
not i don't know man this was a lot of
hits look man
not for this though
for you
like
when he was on the bottom he was getting
rid of that was pretty big right i don't
like that you're eating meat when you
insult me like it's close to gonna stop
there it's really close
i don't know about this but here you got
to move or fight back now we're starting
to get six seven eight nine ten and he's
adding he's moving right there what's up
but he's like they do finally let go and
he said i'm good he said i'm good he did
say i'm good
yeah matt you want someone here
back there i'm not gonna be the only one
letting you drink
alone it is a real cocktail dude i know
he needs to miss his drink i know man i
mean i needed you yeah you never listen
i just show up and i just do what i'm
told baby that's it you know what i'm
saying drinking buddies
yeah i love it can you get that spot
over there we need it we need to have
cal and give you as well do you have
like a uniform in the pool or do you do
you come like you know is it like a
tight fit shirt can you knock on the
door i wear whatever i really want to
wear to be totally honest everybody else
wears like the company's called burton
pools so everybody else like wears like
burton pool stuff or whatever else i i
should put some fights in there probably
a good chance that happened sometime too
but meathead pools
nate's a good dude nate burton he's a
really good dude he uh he's actually
been pool punching it's cool like we
were cool before but we weren't like
witness like friends were just cool and
now like our relationship's kind of
grown really well we communicate very
well we have differences all the time
about stuff like as far as what clients
to take on how to do it what to charge
whatever the position is superior um
yeah obviously but he obviously knows
how to throw my dick on the table and
he's like oh goodness yeah because i
imagine where you're at there's a lot of
you know
i don't even know where you are
he's in uh indiana oh i'm in
apparently anthony smith broke his ankle
that's what he said
was that with a little [ __ ] yeah
it can't be good for food drugs oh [ __ ]
yeah
bro stop being so selfish jesus
broke his ankle [ __ ] you can't come on
my youtube show
he looks like ram man it's not as tall
as ramen wow
well when you know what you're doing my
brother was born and my and when my
brother was born you know how they say
like it's tough for the older like you
know sibling because like the attention
is now off
my grandpa got me a [ __ ] ram man
action figure to give to me the day my
brother was born so i could have
something like to do and i got the
rayman action victor and everyone's like
oh cool that's ramen you love ram man
and i l and i was [ __ ] three and a
half and i said give it to your brother
he only no no
that would be the nice thing to do i
said you only got me this because he's
here now i put it down
i mean how often do you think a ram man
zero times but whenever i don't know who
that is that's what i think do you know
who that is raymond he's a he-man
yeah which one well i can't believe you
think okay you thought about it jim
bring up a brand man hey can we get matt
a goddamn cup for i'm gonna start
typically there's 19 bros back there
rand man it is a [ __ ] festival bring
some meat where do you break
bring more meat dude he got [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] how did he break his
ankle they just twist it or kicking
that's tough thank you mark thank you
your friend what do you say right ram is
it rna
yes sir
rams it's like juggernaut in the next
matter you guys see this don't
joke joe's going to get his feelings oh
maybe oh
he's like a little bowling ball oh wow
wow that does look like rogan i'll give
you that look that looks like broken in
a suit there we go if he put on a pair
of shoes oh yeah yeah that was a great
reference
that little toy you could push on his
head right and he would just bring in
the stuff dude yeah but i would buy that
right now oh that's cool bro wow i
haven't seen this [ __ ] in a long time i
should get this are you gonna have like
emotional flashbacks right now it kind
of is like that well look at this one
the realist realistic version hey chris
have you ever uh bought something for
your son or asked him to watch something
that you grew up watching and they're
like [ __ ]
oh
i'm used to [ __ ] moana you're making
me watch animaniacs are you out of your
mind i tried to watch change ninja
turtles he wasn't really feeling it dude
how could you there's a new one though
on netflix how could you not be in the
[ __ ] really tinnies
that's the best
yo that's terence crawford next he looks
good jesus hey when i saw mike stop
whipping that dude's ass on the airplane
i know
i'm not going to touch him but you got
to think like it he didn't just go after
him it was like so long
he was harassing him you know the guy
but like
and you know the thoughts he must have
had like i'm going to kill this
[ __ ] everything in his brain
must be like no don't and he's done a
lot of work on himself oh like that guy
must have been dude it's it's wild how
many like reels he has of like
pontification of like like genuine
thought like life yeah like deep like
you know like like do you ever see the
real i don't know if you're on the
internet at all or whatever whatever you
do or you're just [ __ ] awesome
naturally i don't know but like it's
weird to watch him there was somebody
talking about anger and he was like oh i
can't forgive this dude for that and
he's like you lost he's like you lost
he's like that dude changed you yeah he
sticks with you for the rest of your
life he's like if you think i won yeah
and i was like
[ __ ] dude like
shrooms and he's just in a different
world
but you look at his journey though i
mean that's a big journey to go on to
get to that point where not all of us
can go on that journey we have to find
that strength and he also knows to lose
all that it's like to be the top of the
world the king of the world have all
that money and then like it all goes
away for you know in comparison but then
you go these ups and downs nobody but it
went away people stole from donkeys
he got [ __ ] over but then also you
know grew up with a father she had a
tiger at a party
nobody i celebrate that i actually gave
a [ __ ] about him they just don't use it
he's so cognizant of the fact that he
was used and that he has a position to
say like uh i'm so happy because you
can't take anything from me anymore
although did you see there was a press
conference that he was at it for some
reason and don king was there and he's
going around saying what's up and he
touched him and uh uh tyson goes don't
[ __ ] touch me dude
king who's the guy who stole from him
all these years and don king's going
around and it's like the legend of
boxing he goes what's up man don't
[ __ ] touch me
well where's the ayahuasca stole from
him
where's the ayahuasca vibes no but he's
like yeah i thought you forgave him oh
yeah but you still touching you good i
mean
but he's
you're still a piece of [ __ ] yeah i just
don't carry it well what it is is you
can forgive somebody but there's still
wounds but you don't forgive you don't
forgive someone for them you forgive
them for yourself so you don't have to
[ __ ] deal with that [ __ ] and
landscapes
you don't forgive somebody for them hey
where's the [ __ ] meatloaf for christ
can i get some meat around here dude
when somebody talks like that i'm like
that's what jesus said yes
so because some people it's not you're
not a smart dude but some people will
say something like jesus oh you heard he
saw it on a poster and then i'll be like
then i started seeing a therapist i'm
like okay oh i've i heard that's where
they got that that's what that's so much
like oh god they were giving me advice
they got from the therapist that's what
that dumb guy told me yeah
um by the way i heard marty's back down
in um in fort lauderdale yeah yeah yeah
he's talking about kamar hussman who
also just got announced he's in the next
black panther is he really good for him
dude i'll tell you what man he's our
he's the ufc's pound for pound number
one guy in the world he's 170 pounds
yeah
yeah
i would rather be in black panther
but you can't do this for too long yeah
you know it's like you got it what is
the show and he's always consistently
done like commentary for xmma like he's
always been very involved and i think
he's been cognizant of how much you know
so this one thing we talked about with
rashad um uh that one when i when i was
here and you weren't yeah yeah i
appreciate you no no doubt so we talked
about thanks baby he gave him so much
money so yeah because i'm a grown man
you've already got good hair i'm trying
to get good hair
that's not going to eat all that yeah
but you can have some that uh yeah good
after man you're weird i'm not shy at
all i just have cooties do you code that
yeah i'm cool with your pool cooties
you're chlorine
guys
you beat me
i think i talked about rochelle but i
talked about with marty too like like
how much of the demon are you are you
willing them are you letting them take
from you you know like of your soul like
like how much do you feel like you've
committed so much and you they keep
taking more you say demon i say light
yeah like you're they'll take your light
where when you get done that light's
gone all right let me ask you something
and they use it all i'm hearing that i'm
hearing this conversation and i have to
ask you both this because eight inches
no i'm saying
if
when if the money was say nba-ish
would you have a different feeling about
ufc yeah because then you're set because
then then the juice is worth the squeeze
yeah because now that you do that but is
that part of the animosity or the the
feeling that you've made so
that's a really complicated question and
brandon you finish your thought if you
want
um you said it's part of it oh oh that's
cool um what the [ __ ] is this bro i i
don't know i i don't want to make i
don't i don't know what is this that's
really right
before i say anything i want to see
what's going on
is that like make a wish thing i don't
want to make fun of it no no it was for
some show oh that music
yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry what were you
saying though what were you saying i'm
asking is like because i hear
you talk about this a lot
and now i'm hearing other fighters and i
have my other friend eric coke i mean
it's always about like it's like this is
so hard and it's like i feel like the
compensation is not enough
would the whole business be different
if it's good question the money would if
you were set matt you know what i'm
saying like it was a five million dollar
purse every minimum every time you
fought
what what are we talking about if the
pay was like nfl because
yeah yeah it was like you know
minimum pay nfl you have also have
benefits you have 401k there's there's
all you get done you haven't that's
it's going to happen sooner or later not
in our lifetime i don't think so you
don't think no dude
[ __ ] changes quickly yeah it doesn't
know all right so so my i'm a very
complicated moderately loaded answer to
that oh i love i i'm curious okay so
i think what i feel
is that
if you are if you are a person that
causes damage if you're a striker
your job gets harder the older you get
the reason is is because you have family
you have children you have aunts uncles
you have nieces nephews right you have
people in your lives and you realize
that they do also
and so you cause physical damage
irreparable damage at times to said
person and then they have to go home and
be irreparably different to their family
and it
weighs so heavily i'm not playing a
sport
i'm fighting for my life and i'm
fighting to take your pride because your
pride is gonna only thing that says it's
gonna kill you to keep getting up
right so i'm fighting for your pride
that's the belt i wear it's not the
championship though it's i took
everybody's pride you're also taking
half of his income wow
so for me to be cognizant of the damage
created my cause to a family
it's harder for me to become the same
person i was when i was younger and more
naive or less readily acceptable to that
concept and part and part of that is
knowing the fact that also there isn't
enough compensation for what i've done
to this person yeah all right yeah you
can say that but but money is a
completely side issue the only thing
about money until after the fact the
money show in it the money is not cause
you can't think about the money because
if you do you're different yeah you're
fine you fight safe you can't fight for
money yeah unless you're floyd
mayweather so then do you think that
that would change the sport
no if i think i i i to his point i think
there'd be less resentment from retired
fighters if they were set i think that
why can i agree and i'm not saying
money's not a part because the [ __ ]
obviously it is but
we're not playing a sport and i think
that the fact that we're not playing a
sport i think it makes it harder and i
think that's the reason why
we get we the older generation right
like i'm like brendan and i i've since i
just retired right i'll go ahead and
throw myself in here well you know a
part of the old crowd right we're the
old school group where we didn't come up
doing it we just got into doing it um
i'm the robert parish in the ufc
and like you would just drink in your
hands saying that it's ridiculous
i'm the jerry west of the ufc it's
amazing that they
uh have been able to go days in the ufc
have been able to go as far as they have
off the backs of so many people because
they can't put it put aside any
financial differences and unionize and
be like hey man or associate and be like
hey there has to be something here
greater than there's something better
than the greater good and but and this
is why they've tried it before and i was
i was actually involved it's close
they've ever come they got one of the
guy the guy who put together because the
best uh like union in all of
professional sports is mlb they split
profits 50 50. and they're sad men
guaranteed money so bobby manila is
still getting paid for the new york
times but yeah now right now it's like 9
million a year because he signed a
contract 20 years ago like nothing's
better than mlb so they got the guy who
set that up to represent the fighters
they called me you in should i go who's
involved they tell me oh it sounds like
you got a shot here i'm on board
search going through the motions all
that stuff i'm talking to him every
[ __ ] week and then we had big names
i'm not gonna say who it is we had big
names involved danny gets word of it
goes to those big names goes
shut up and they go yeah i know say less
say less
because so that that's you know it's
just like because it doesn't it doesn't
make sense for them to to rock the boat
yeah because here you go little buddy
right right wow
who wouldn't do that you know everybody
would but you need a guy like connor who
has all the money in the world where
danny goes shut up meals
what are you doing yeah i spend that on
gucci sheets dude yeah the [ __ ] out of
it yeah my yacht that's gas money for my
yacht get out of here you know
um but those guys are so compensated
that they're not going to rock the boat
that's what it is um so i i don't know
if you got an answer out of all that
blabber no no no i i get your sentiment
and i understand i
i feel um
i feel both of your guys is sort of like
not i don't want to use the word
resentment that's not i don't understand
words it's not the word that's what i'm
saying i'm i'm i'm glad
i feel like it's like there is a part of
you that wishes this was better
yeah now listen you have two guys with
ct trying to explain this to you yeah
that's part of the problem but the other
thing is
you both got successful business he does
pools you guys for sure if but if i will
say this like i i have no issues with
data and people think i have vision i
have zero issues because when i when i
was kind of retiring and getting to
stand up and podcasting because the way
he treated me you know the people like
oh he has a chip on his shoulder
[ __ ] i had a box of pringles on my
[ __ ] shoulder so it gave me this fuel
to build this and hustle and stand up
and then you know i'm friends with chris
who's work ethic to me and i've chosen
but chris is work ethic dude
professional athletes nobody has a
better workout than chris chris never
late does
how many sets of [ __ ] week wow and i
was trying to keep up with him yeah i
was trying to keep up with him so you
know what i'm saying so i had that
benefit so i had this chip on my
shoulder so that gave me the fuel to
build all this stuff and then once i got
out of the the you know the kind of
chaos of everything i was like oh thank
you dude dana thank you for [ __ ] me
over dude and you didn't mean to like
it's not like he was like almost signed
this reebok deal to [ __ ] brendan over
he's like i'm signing this reebok deal
because the ufc my business is gonna
benefit because i'm trying to package
this [ __ ] up and sell it correct and
they sold for two billion dollars so
it's like oh yeah oh yeah you have a
business that makes sense but so then
once i looked at the perspective like oh
you're doing what's best for you
and that helped me out i'm good man yeah
but i said i have zero issues
and i'm gonna cut you off go ahead dan
did a great job and explain explaining
this at some of the summits right the
fighter summit said to bring everybody
in
and what his position would be real
quick so the summit is once a year they
bring in every single person on the
roster to las vegas and it's kind of
like the uh for the nfl what do you
think yeah like that like the uh
combined like the yeah the rookie
symposium the imposing so they have they
have older fighters right hey make sure
you look out for this and people are
going to ask for your money or usually
family and invest your money in this
yeah there's the kids
role-playing things you know so a whole
is going to walk up to you and be like
she's going to be like
i can't pay my rent
no i remember my year they had michael
the wig yeah the mustache yeah
i'll tell you this right now i was in
double team just on the field fellas
y'all wait what
how how am i investing my money dana did
a great job of expressing this is that
this is not a job it's not a career it
is an opportunity and that is all this
is so if you decide to make this your
career then that is on you but what i'm
doing is i'm giving you an opportunity
to make a name and financial positioning
but it's also like stand up you know
what i'm saying like stand up it's like
yeah but that's
on you you know what i'm saying but
that'd be like the club owner saying to
you like yeah you can sell your merch
yeah you know i'm not gonna i don't need
to pay you a lot because yeah you can
sell your merch i mean and it sounds to
me like this is like if you're like
you're owning a starbucks but you don't
have to pay for the coffee that you use
no because you still pay for them but
you but let's say uh uh a cup of coffee
is three dollars you're taking two
dollars and ninety dude there's a bottom
line
yeah it's two but it's too young of a
sport oh they're still in leather
helmets
they're too young of a sport yeah but
but see i i don't i reject wait hold on
a second i reject that because
you already know all the other sports
now that that's
being too young of a sport i don't care
because there are other sports but
there's others you can you can you can
see the governments are the same way
there's still like new governments and
[ __ ] but here's my thinkers
they've been around since this must be
500. this is going to be fine by the way
so yeah these two did not play i mean we
can keep talking about ufc's issues
this fight of the night wow but um
would you say the thing that the show
knew doesn't work because they've been
around since yeah yeah they've been said
yeah
and then also they sold for two billion
dollars yeah
four billion dollars you keep saying two
it's four even i know that because chin
corrected you but oh wow look at this
dude that's like what calvin does to me
you know i'm saying so to say they're in
infancy doesn't work for me because you
have yeah wme owns them they have not
been forced to they have their head they
have not had their hand before
here's my question for the three of you
if you're and this is the way i i view
it it helps me sleep at night if you're
dana white
what would you do
what do you mean oh i'm saying like yeah
like if i'm dating i'm like i run a
business it's it's not my job to make
sure you guys get your [ __ ] together
eventually when you do i'm willing to
play ball right now it's like wrangling
[ __ ] cats you guys just take by the
time you guys get together i'm gonna be
out of the game yeah yeah it's so
realistic but also you're mad at the ufc
be mad at apple what did you say no no
no no
like i know how far you want nobody
wants to pay anybody more that's weird
me defending ufc pay but i'm just saying
it's on the fi i i dipped out
that did not take long oh she choked
my ass
wow
but chris it would be like now that
you're not a great community is there
another celebration if you're a
headliner can we get a new celebration
is it all jump on the camera standing on
this uh jumping like you know what i did
it just my fault for saying that i
didn't know these guys because those
little [ __ ] scrapped they went in
through hands dude got caught in a choke
coolest way [ __ ] works but [ __ ] good
for them man hey i would have loved if
it would have been like a you know a
better kiss than that
oh
that would make the today show if
they're just like
oh yeah we're gay yeah we just fought
we've been [ __ ] for years this is my
soul mate oh wait let's see how it is he
is the best ass in the business he gives
the best dome ever
that's such a
spider monkey man
good for him oh did he did this a
submission yeah
that guy got the submission about to get
dumb oh don't say oh that should hurt
another break your name no no i know i'm
just stuck on my i didn't realize it was
this look at him passionately squeezing
look at that that was on his face
[Music]
i bet his teeth
no that that will break your neck chris
it's almost like you pop your teeth out
it'll break your neck because yeah
you're twisting it when it's here yeah
it's like a jaw it's worse yeah it was
on when his forearm went across his
teeth it hurts his roots popping has
anyone died
not in the ufc oh why do you gotta like
i mean i mean seriously there's one up
too yeah everybody's parade right now no
they've they've died outside of you so
yeah
there's a dude i'll tell you what's not
gonna kill you cancer yeah i'll tell you
what's not gonna kill you let's take a
little break fellas from this
talk yeah i'll tell you what's not gonna
kill you kratom and i swear by it i use
kratom to fight my brain for a podcast
stand up it's my limit it's like
limitless oh
dude you're different i'm like bradley
cooper bro you're focused it's your
focus oh my god the best part is ready
it's all natural daddy i take happy
hippo kratom before i do stamp whatever
i'm doing it's freaking happy hippo
kratom's like what cbd used to be is the
wild west but if you're gonna trust
kratom you gotta trust happy hippo all
right visit happyhippo herbals.com use
promo code thick boy for 20 off for life
son use that code as many times as you
want enjoy if you want to try kratom
happy hippos it happy hippo
herbals.com use promo code thick boy 20
off for life you know what this guy i
love you
little
yeah they're little 125 pounds are you
saying because compared to joe yeah no
no because i'm saying because joe's a
he's not a
he's not tall yeah yeah yeah you know
what i mean i don't think people rush
yeah joe's shorter yeah dude do you
remember that joey's getting dressed up
all the time and then i i never knew he
had sleeves i never knew it and then i
said i saw him yeah
he also has his skin condition he does
his vitiligo yeah does he really yeah so
his hands have like spots oh i can see
it right now yeah you can see it all
right no [ __ ] huh
good for joe man hey that [ __ ] will make
tattoos look crazy like little uh scotty
jorgensen mm-hmm that'd do that nuts
yeah no rogan's tattoos are all colorful
too with his uh fair skin looks dope i
decided not to get my sleeve why you
ready one i was i was gonna get one i
don't have anything
none no hold on why you're so young yeah
right like i got mine [ __ ] late he
had a neck tattoo last week [ __ ] four
he's 40. yeah yeah it's ridiculous
you know why
i want one so bad you know why but then
he's been stopping all right now that's
why [ __ ] got nothing else to
accomplish everyone you got copies
on the other side
gives a [ __ ] i i hate that you did it
before me now i can't do it not do it no
after 40. no i have to do it on the
front i have to do on the front though
i'll do it with you
like your family
boom i got to get more faces oh yeah you
got to get more famous because i'm like
one bad breaker away from where but then
you have to shave your neck you don't
you can do whatever it's in like
whatever you like
you can get a 40 on your neck airplane
on your arm what do you guys have
sentiments on derrick lewis
i him in texas is uh clearly a mental
block
why would you have to be like oh we know
you struggle to fight in texas and you
need to win headlines
fight in dallas where are they are they
fighting
dallas yeah wow no right now it's
houston right oh this is this is his own
town oh no it is south this is dallas
dallas that's so funny i mentioned
dallas because i'll be in dallas august
26th i'm playing the texas trust cu uh
center and you still struggle with the
name of it and that's fine i don't know
what the name is but it's a grand
prairie yeah dallas it's giant yeah it's
chrisley.com you get tickets isn't that
[ __ ] hilarious that you're brought up
dallas and i'm going to be there and
you're watching my face because you're
in giant theaters but listen i'm glad
you brought that up i'm in baltimore
next time thursday friday night got some
bullets there work on your matrix
movement i heard but rayleigh's killer
guy he's fine and then also i'm in
chicago 26 one not only den theater
chicago friday night one show 7 30
chicago den theater is friday night
august 26th appleton wisconsin september
ontario boston we'll see you guys i also
got a bunch of other days i'll be in
wichita be in atlanta but whatever yeah
go to airgriffin.com i'm at la jolla
comedy store ninth tenth and all there
you go
i'm building pools in indiana you guys
want to come by and say yeah because you
guys are all like i'm here i'm there i'm
doing this i'm jumping out of a cake and
then i have my one here no energy eric's
oh that's a little dude huh uh
volkanovsky yeah he's just [ __ ] tough
tough tough as they come he used to be
240 pounds yeah played rugby
yeah muscle
uh
no no not myself not muscle but he's so
small yeah
rugby is 240 pounds yeah thick little
dude um
you know what fort wayne uh it was i was
on the set of uh i was on the set of um
uh stranger things right so that's
strange things my airbnb was haunted as
[ __ ] and i asked my opener who was from
there i go what's there to do he goes
this one i know i was in trouble
um
in fort wayne no [ __ ] miami yeah fort
wayne he goes um there's a single a
baseball team the stadium's pretty cool
all right let's go there so we walked
there i got a jersey okay here we go and
that was all there is to do okay but i
actually really enjoyed it let's go back
i really enjoyed it because it's so
different than from l.a yeah i like
those small towns i love the vibe yeah
there's nothing to do
yeah i would have been your friend
but that's two that's two and a half
hours away and i was like dude i'm not
the drive from where i live to fort
wayne is the worst drive of all time
might as well drive through kansas yeah
where are you at two and a half hours
from my mom so i understand i appreciate
that where are you i live in west
lafayette indiana purdue university
um and purdue's not bad but um there's
not much outside of it indianapolis is
an hour away it's where we go that's
what i have to fly out of um um oh i'm
glad you mentioned purdue i'm still
waiting for my my call start jersey oh
wait let's talk about something real
quick alice oh i was gonna do this in a
minute if i got her girl oh you brought
it right mike also was like my favorite
player as a kid growing up and he's
really good friends when he played
football with him and uh who's this what
do we talk about mike alstott he's like
the greatest white running back of all
time he's my favorite player as a kid of
course
he was so [ __ ] good he's really good
friends with him i don't get it
because he had to find the one white
okay i thought that might be it
thank you so much
you can have whatever you like
hey you wanna alt jersey whatever the
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] his name
you want a white running back jersey
hey i hope you enjoyed that do you think
you open it like a meat head yeah oh
never mind you already do it you got
that handled like open it like a piece
of [ __ ] meathead oh you got that hand
he's opening in the like what happened
like superman
i think don't get greasy superman
he's a really good friend of mine do me
a favor he's like dude no problem
whatsoever
yeah
i hope you like your brother hey and
i'll tell you this
he's a [ __ ] great dude he is a human
being he is [ __ ] dead how's his brain
i remember this guy
my gosh
he's absolutely fantastic you know
what's amazing about mike i know
baseball so he's he's extremely he's
extremely humble for for what mike is
doing
um
we're talking one day about um chris
berman gary carter and i was like hey
man legitimately how much did chris
berman help out your career because mike
had these crazy runs and nobody ever
would pay attention if chris berman
didn't bring all the attention it'll be
like you guys have got to show this
because when he would truck people
and then go whoop yeah yeah when he
would when he freaked out yep
he's like do i can be totally honest
with you mike had three contracts with
the buccaneers right first one is when
you you get drafted you get money the
second one's when you get your real
money third one is like is nest egg
money that's all it is that's
generational we're going sizzling yeah
so
mike goes i i guarantee you i would have
been a been traded or be not gotten my
third contract if it wasn't for chris
burnley no he became a gary guy he's a
superstar his boys are super robbed boys
thick these boys yeah i want you to
watch david blue hot spots what even
this guy's thinking
uh fought one of my teammates i was
supposed to fight stephen struve seventh
street seven foot one big ass dude uh
you were gonna fight how tall are you
yeah uh six three oh okay okay
go ahead
real quick before you go on i need to
brag about matt real quick so matt
fought derek lewis who's the greatest
knockout artist in the history matt
knocked him out how long matt uh 41
seconds with his hip so be cool with
your head it was actually number
shoveling
like saturday night sunday night because
it was like a memorial day weekend or
something like that
and um and i was supposed to fight drew
strove had a heart issue and couldn't
fight like 15 minutes for the fight
we're warming up going to start
scrapping his heart issue they had to
cancel the fight [ __ ] so i'm not just
i'm drunk as [ __ ] i'm having a great
time this is the next night this is the
second night of the double-headed oh my
so i'm drunk i'm having a good time and
uh derek lewis fights one of my
teammates
great stand up guy for some reason he
just uh guto innocent he was a really
good stand-up guy but he just had a
horrible night that night maybe the
lights got to him whatever else the
pressure he absolutely collapsed got
smoked so derek beats my teammate and
he's saying something to crowds loud
whatever else i'm dancing because the
music's playing whatever else and
everybody starts looking at me like what
just happened what just happened and
like and then i see uh brad smuckler
who's like the financial guy the
comptroller for the ufc he's looking at
me he's like are you going to say yes
what's going on here he just called you
out by name yeah i think you said this
out by name and i was so i was so
offended that that [ __ ]
mispronounced my name when he called me
out that i was like absolutely put my
name on the bottom line i told him i was
like listen i am going to stand over
your unconscious body after i sleep with
you for saying my name out loud for
calling me out in public that's what the
[ __ ] going to happen you got your name
wrong
what do you call you call me matron
you know that's just a [ __ ] accent or
no no
and he's the best knockout arson you see
his this dude yeah yeah how old he hits
like i don't know he's full hey also no
he's [ __ ] dope yeah
he has a personality yeah yeah his
instagram is lit he's funny as [ __ ] yeah
he's a he's a how old is this guy for
real 37 37 oh man and also he spent a
[ __ ] time i think i don't know how much
time in prison but he spent time in
prison so like he's really appreciative
towards his life now like he's a [ __ ]
good dude he's a father a husband really
good dad yeah i had him on when i did uh
below the belt for show time he won the
first guest yeah and he was like you got
to see you you're like this chris you're
like so he has a bunch of kids yeah and
i was talking to him about fighting he
was he was can be honest man worst thing
about fighting when i lose and he was
like five kids he was like come home my
kids make fun of me oh that's hilarious
i don't want to go home this belly
button is deep enough to do you know
what i mean that's that was the prison
he spent time right in there
oh my god just take his belly dude
god dude and that's it thanks for coming
out
you take that belly and just hit it bro
youtube's going like this
good for him
what a great win for you matt i i wonder
what um
i wonder what
amount of bonuses he's got wow like
locker bunch so hey this other thing you
like about him chris because we like
cars right we like cars you don't know
the cars but you like driving cars yeah
and he also drives a lamborghini uh
huracan and he looks like wreck-it ralph
in it right because big guys can't drive
him yes because of black i love how his
shorts don't fit this guy's my hero and
this dude is taking his shorts off
but when he wins when he wins they give
him the mic dude just goes after one of
his wins he goes they go uh what are you
doing he's like yeah i gotta take a [ __ ]
man he said he ran off yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's out here well i i've seen
this yeah
i've seen that oh he's like my balls was
hot so i took my shorts
you know dude that's one of the things i
i really admire about rogan is that that
dude rolls with every [ __ ] point yeah
everything that he is so cool that's the
comedian like that guy's been [ __ ]
that's why he would stand up for how
perfect that's perfect yeah they can't
the fighters aren't gonna say anything
that surprises me no they'll play off
what's the advantage okay guys fighting
i'm because i'm not into this as much as
you know so who's got the advantage here
derrick lewis
this kid's he's surging he's a [ __ ]
monster you gotta remember something uh
yeah eight youth most likely yeah yeah
30 137. he's this guy's a russian right
uh-huh yeah he was a russian but
he's a
guy he's uh he's a [ __ ] guy he's he's
probably a very good grappler um
probably decently stoic as far as like
he does has a good poker face so you
don't know when you hurt him um and
that's frustrating fighting somebody who
has a good poker face is tough really
why is that yeah i've never been
thinking that's every russian though
right yeah no i know is it because
they're having a good time that's very
funny yes that's it but is it because
you don't know do you stand up in russia
do stand up and wrestle let me know how
it goes yeah i might end up fighting in
russia we had great come on guys i might
fight in russia come on guys nobody
gonna find out and then after that
but after the show in the meet and greet
there everybody's like
you look so funny
at the time in my whole life
this is the best time of my life
and what was that uh
who was that
natasha and uh uh boris right abortion
natasha that's what it was hell yeah
well done right he is spilling out of
these shorts yeah
exactly
you know they made a movie and robert de
niro played the dude
yeah
robert
so real quick so he looks like a
chocolate ice cream cone you're still
talking about his belly button
no i'm just like hey here's the thing
derrick lewis slow starter all he has to
do is land one punch and it's over keep
your feet you can't make a mistake it's
over yeah now if he goes in the later
rounds he gets a little different i'll
say derek's really good at power
slamming people like he's very strong so
he can he's
very strong yeah that guy looks like no
his powers honestly both of these dudes
look like so right now look out derek
throwing backwards to me that does not
bode well for derek got it because derek
doesn't fight well going backwards right
in my in my experience do you got did
any of these ufc guys ever like start a
business of being like a like a
bodyguard or like getting into that kind
of thing well they probably come from
that well you know frank mayer and roy
nelson were uh head security experiment
rhino in vegas i've never been but i
heard it's a strip club out there oh
derek's in sleep
oh [ __ ] this russian is not [ __ ]
around yeah
he's hurt having a great time having a
great day doesn't want to do it derek's
done no derek doesn't want to do it
anymore yeah that's it
it's over that's it wow this is a quick
these are quick fights
yeah but they're heavy weights so you
can't let this guy
he's this is what you're supposed to do
right this is what you see you have to
do this you know what i do wait till i
tell my friend my very last fight when
travis brown when they stopped that i
got up on what the [ __ ] am i i want to
thank god really that's funny bro i
pretended i was mad that's funny i
called acting like like i'm saying i
think he's doing that right now too
would you do it man but dude you have to
these guys was like this would you do it
oh i was like i can't believe you
stopped
there's so much in this here and i
guarantee dude he's made he's made
really good money he's pretty he's
probably relatively financially set for
the rest of his life and i'm i don't
mean to speak out of here
he was like i was retired i didn't want
he's like i don't love doing fighting
man
and he goes but then the ufc offered me
so much money i was like [ __ ] it i'll do
it when he told me i'm like ah dude
that's definitely yeah but
it's tough like this it's hard to keep
going though right well no no
this this i mean the easiest reason for
him to get the [ __ ] out
yeah this is it yeah like so it's not
hard for him to keep going he was
looking for a reason to be safe
i can make a bunch of money you got to
win fights right no no he's such a big
draw he's such a draw but he's like
yeah yeah well dude he's [ __ ] giant
he's black as a [ __ ] he leads
the [ __ ] world and and knockouts and
fights and victories and whatever else
that dude can fight as long as he
[ __ ] wants to turn his belly button
people go to him because of his belly
button i mean he's gotta you can get
seats in there
he does he does a meet and greet with
the belly button afterwards
people get to play
[Applause]
during the fight during the fight like
as a thought derek was ranked six this
guy was ranked number 15 or something or
whatever it was like 11 i think sure so
it didn't matter to derrick anymore he's
like cool man so i'm going to retire
anyways
he looks like he's mad he knows he's the
he's the old guard and this dude's a
young guy that sounds great what's a
person on a fight like this for you're
totally different 500 grand yeah
probably and this guy probably made
thirty thousand dollars yes that's why
he's so happy because he's going back to
work he's made 60. he just made 60 grand
like yeah well he and he didn't make 60
because he's got to give like you know
yeah there we go
you
would the ufc have a pr problem if he
got on the mic was like we got to kill
more ukrainians oh my god i think they
would they'd be like cut his mic yeah
reagan does a joke
um you know just as a thought too
is that uh
this guy here has so much potential and
and i'm i'll get kind of worried about
with the position that dana sees himself
falling into is that there are so many
daggers and he's rushing instead
whatever the number one problem that
you're losing your audience and they
can't sell pay-per-views over across the
board you're only losing your audience
in america in america they're good but
they have the espn they have the espn
deal they're all what i think the ufc is
doing is they're going we've done all we
can in america we've we've made our mark
here international's our only bro so
much
yeah that's got a [ __ ] i mean as a
heavyweight two people stop tuning in
yeah i think only higher asians
for everything there's not many asian
heavyweights are there oh there's none
sir how about that one dude wonder boy
or what's his name that only gets
him he just gets hit in the head and
never gets never falls out i saw a fight
with that dude he never goes down huh
he's also 40 right so i want to change
them from wonder boy to wonder man yeah
and i'm going to keep trying to do that
and he's not into it
i respect that
i see where you're going with that thing
there's izzy
still rocking the pearls
even for a guy like me who takes faster
than rich it's too much for me what is
too much for me pearls the pearls that's
right
it's like tight it's like a choker
that's cool i like that i'm going to do
that yeah i could see you doing that so
now it's the wait what is one more fight
you know how about this let's talk about
this for a minute marty is in a bad
position because there's nobody for him
to fight
well he says he didn't go to [ __ ]
light heavyweight which i think is
insane
martial
because he doesn't want to fight
middleweight because uh izzy's that
middleweight and he's african even
though they're not even
training partners just because he's
african he doesn't want to fight him
yeah so
he's like i'ma jump to light heavyweight
and fight who marty did you hear they
canceled that jake paul fight they're
not going to do it yeah there's a wait
there's a i guess um i heard about that
contract though by the way i tried to
get that fight
there's no way out that would ever get
happening sir i mean i tried to yeah
like when dude yeah when dude fell out
the first guy yeah i was like hey throw
my name in there yeah yeah yeah like
i'll i'll go but you know they yeah for
sure yeah yeah no i mean i know
obviously yeah he's too big yeah
i know i mean they're fighting favor and
russia right
news there but whatever hey listen i'll
tell you where what you got to do if you
do fight fedor in russia you got to make
sure you don't have a bush dude that's
where manscape product alert
you ask for eric they listen brother
because you're harry i can see on your
forearms dude our friends at manscape
just brought back the ultra smooth
package it's time to stop drop and order
this premium shaving cream
everyone knows by now that the lawnmower
4.0 get your fingers electrical for your
balls but if you're looking for a closer
save to go bear down there then the
ultra smooth package is the perfect set
it's time to shave the bush of yours all
right get right to the route and you'll
get a little discount just for you
fellas or ladies if you have a hairy uh
shoulder or something get 20 off and
free shipping at medscape.com with the
code cfc dude this smooth package what's
come with eric i'm glad you asked again
your knuckles have jumanji hairs on them
all right step one you get the crop of
foliator step two crop gel step three
it's time to shave the crop shaver was
designed for shaving that little
sensitive area i'm talking about you're
growing your nuts fellas all right we
got you it's time to get up close and
personal the best tools for the job the
ultra smooth package from landscape get
20 off in free shipping with the code
cfc at manscape.com that's 20 off free
shipping with the code cfc manscape.com
smooth out your fellas with the relaunch
ultra smooth package from the fellas at
manscape your balls will thank you you
know what's crazy too is that you
mention uh dallas i will be there in
august august 26th to be in dallas so go
to chrisley get tickets out by the texas
san diego
and eleventh
in september hey guys
[ __ ] ferocious squirrel's nest down
in my pants right now and i could really
use some of that manscaping yeah but
take
what is the landscape manscaping gel
what is that that you gel your pubes and
you put them in designs and then you
should yeah sure you know like those
twisty mustaches yeah like there's
something here you can just
do it
i can get my handlebar
essential essential oils dude it's like
a spa treatment for your job yeah i
gotta do i gotta shave my knuckles me
being married is nice rachel thinks i
don't have my ring on sometimes you know
oh and i have to go
outside his knuckles look at his
knuckles come here
okay hey listen dude like when you when
you jerk off it's like [ __ ] animal
from the muppets going dude
that's funny bro
it's the cookie monster is going through
it with the ram man and that [ __ ] yeah
you're a better comedian than i would be
fighter and that's what that's what
drives you not yeah yeah you won't know
till you find out yeah
what's up
hey what's up lamar odom what's up
swaggy p come get something yeah hey
aaron carter holler and carlos
how's that [ __ ] you'd fight aaron carter
more than [ __ ] uh odom how about
loser gets a face tattoo yeah he's
already got one sorry i'll be done for
the facebook i don't know the thing is
i'm already 42 so
if i was if i was 20 now you can't be
fighting i i would no no what talk about
face tattoos if i was 20 now i bet i
would get a facebook you're the only
comedian 42
and you're fine no you don't die don't
die anything are you sure everything
you've got a lot of wisdom in your beard
but there's none of time everyone thinks
i [ __ ] they're always like you got
your hair bro his father's you don't
have any either gandalf
yeah you don't have any gray oh i got
gray i got gray a lot up here
that mustache no out of control yeah
there's no gray in it no not really at
all maybe a couple stragglers but your
hair doesn't look dyed you you don't you
just but you're but you're there you got
like a beautiful mop
me and eric have the most gray like i'm
turning to jay leno over here dude i
want greg
i want gray there's there's gandalf over
there you're way ahead of the game are
you talking about but you actually don't
have really gray hair on your head
like get silver or just have some
schedules
yeah i think i think that when i hit
silver bro
okay and so am i with this get up with
the silver bro i know you roll your eyes
but bro cause you get it that's why
because you don't have to have a staff
you're gonna be like you shall not pass
i thought you meant i think you meant
his staff like people behind me yes yes
i literally i was like what is he doing
where is he going with this thing here
that was the lord of the rings i know i
know i know you're a nerd
the um you you do a good ass job with
your wig man you always guys i wish i
was a wig you're one of the very few
people that i know that can pull off 13
different hairstyles and none of them
look really bad on you it's just
whatever like except the emo one he did
look terrible that emo one
is that this one here yeah yeah i put it
over yeah portland emo
yeah i remember that one
that might have been the one that kind
of swung on me
it's just what's happening what are you
doing
no you got a great head of hair you got
a great head of hair i have a lot of
hair but it's pushed back i think that's
as far as it's probably going to go no
because my dad his is like here and it's
stopped and no one's you're good too
we're good i got i going from here yeah
yeah the only friend we have who is
shitty here is count
but it works for him though you know
what i'm saying
no no in the right lighting well but
i'll tell him he stays in the shadows
i'll tell him like dude we gotta stop
the show
i'll tell him i'm like we gotta we gotta
read like this he learns
to protect it yeah it's just like but
his wrinkles go from like here
you know what i mean well he doesn't
have a bag he doesn't have a bad head
though right you know what i mean i
thought i'm shaving that would mess him
up you've got a horrendous head who are
you telling him you know what i mean
like i gotta look at myself like you
need this thing bro if i if i
you lose your hair right yeah take your
sails that's your take cells look
you know like a roller coaster you know
that's a lot of pressure are you
rogaining it right now no no no nothing
no special efforts no i've been taking
uh what is it finasteride yeah yeah yeah
but for years just because just you know
i thought we have a friend we do a show
with his name theovan oh he has great
hair yeah
he gets here plugged once a year yeah
really no reason
he likes it from the back of his takes
it from the back to the front elective
surgery
you know why though this hair yeah does
not grow properly
to be here because that's the [ __ ] that
goes wild i think
are you walking backwards
oh went to a car show today with my kids
it's just two i thought about you two
puffy
my two babies like there was like
[ __ ] all the hot rods with the
engines already popped out like the old
like kids are obsessed with it i tell
you every single day
nothing but i gotta get cal every sunday
i i stayed up 24 hours to fly from fort
wayne at 5 00 a.m to make the car show
with my kids that's sunday that's right
it's cool but i was weekend at bernie's
[ __ ] yeah
they're holding you up
who's going to win these fights i wish
this is another little scrapper fight
this is the co-main event this world uh
for the interim world championship fight
oh dude
is this like the intercontinental
championship though right oh because
sometimes
when they're
last fight you guys had it was all
decisions wasn't it
oh that was a easy fight yeah that's
right
and then remember the main fight out on
sugar sean pedro gets stopped early yeah
all right
so is this like the official vaseline
guy yes you can't put vaseline on
yourself yeah they actually they come
back there there's no vaseline
so that's his official job
they rotate okay yeah well that's just
hilarious
like i would love to see like how you
know like there'll be a great they did a
documentary about him
like you know i've always wanted to be a
vaseline guy and it's 20 minutes long a
little monster 20 minute long
documentary it's a four-part like when
he was
[Laughter]
he was like i was a great masturbator
when i was uh
i went for records all the time you know
vaseline was never good people used to
use it say that as a joke but have you
ever really used vaseline
you can't you can't wash it off for you
yeah stays on for two years i'm a dry
tugger buddy you know what i mean it's
too greasy you feel like you're you know
the way nature intended i go dry daddy
yeah
i don't need a whole ordeal i need
lotion dry
dry wait dry yeah you guys are dry
[ __ ]
he's like don't be crazy man dude red
i'm saying everything
we got to get chris has to weigh in on
this he really does yeah he does
these dry [ __ ]
can't trust a dry jerker guy yeah that
just it's too much of an ordeal i mean
it's time to go on a route man like
listen i'm not trying to make a
festivity out of this no
deal it's already embarrassing at my age
he's choking me again shut up kid i've
been in a hotel daddy what are you doing
in the ocean i'll get the conditioner
you
i gotta get okay i'll use the condition
using hand sanitizer anything
dry i do brandon marin is a hell of a
scrapper can you please put a poll up on
the youtube
bro the lotion
yeah mark your chris chris you have to
do this you need to weigh in on this
okay these two
dry [ __ ] when you jack off you
have a lotion everything gels is it is
it a spectacle
or is it just no i i i just likes
candles and [ __ ] no i uh
i'm all about foreplay you know all day
i'm just oh my god
here we go i go see a movie by myself
nobody thought that was coming right you
watch a movie
who knew there was a story that's wild
that's why i said dry you're not let me
go like this like this stop
no
not here
not now
time to play christmas
oh man you're so scared you're so silly
come on yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh no i do you really feel that way yeah
oh my god
you're driving me crazy dry would be
like you're just moving your skin that's
because you have so much hair on your
hands
so wait so you don't use anything you
just dry wow
i leave and for to pee and you guys are
already here what's up bro yeah how did
this start
i know how we got here we're talking
about vaseline in the fight you ever
jacked off vaseline no because yeah
stays on your dick for two years for two
years your dick is waterproof no because
chris there's a vaseline guy and i'm
just wondering right right it was like
that guy
was like do you ever see the show the
tudors
and there was a guy bro you've told me
this once before
you but there was a guy it was like like
the king would jack off and there was a
guy that would be like this that's still
character so obviously that's like the
vaseline guy ufc i thought it'd be great
there was like a documentary about him
you know he's like i've always vassily
and that's how he got into the car yeah
right because i was like let's finish
this bed here yeah how are we jacking
off man i use my spit i'm not going to
get up and get [ __ ] lotion oh you're
you're owns he's like this you're a
[ __ ]
it's like superman playing catch with
himself
oh my god that's spinning it was a dog
is that what i just saw no moreno's a
favorite okay oh tonight dancing i mean
they fought before moreno beat him and
he was the dog when they first fought
and he beat him but did get knocked down
those are like really tight
look this guy's five four you 150 pounds
and he's from great britain huh
right
new zealand new zealand [ __ ] yeah
definitely five seven well i'm a [ __ ]
idiot
but whatever you know
uh i think brenton is good but i think
he takes around the same age too he's
fun though yeah he's he's a fun guy to
watch
hey whatever happened to the guy that
used to have that catchphrase or before
fights oh let's get ready for him
his brother and he does boxing right
yeah wow and actually and he's five
hundred thousand every time he says i'm
scared and they're getting a lot of [ __ ]
wrong but they were brothers and they
were both announcing professional sports
who was they they didn't know who they
did not they're adopted yeah oh that's
right that's right they did not know
they were that's right that that is
that should be that's so insanely weird
that everybody on the planet should know
that's a question i totally agree with
you yeah and and i like to be common
knowledge yeah right
do we believe that story ah true good
good point cynical [ __ ] good
point though
good point
good point right there right
that's good i'm very good i'm not saying
bruce is lying i'm saying when i hear
that i'm like yeah that's a good [ __ ]
point right great everything
uh that is a guy that would be in harry
potter he would be in harry potter he
would be the bad guy for sure he would
be dracula we'd have to talk to him yeah
yeah i love it um
what's the serial killer's name we've
got kids right yeah three three yeah
yeah yeah he's that guy's killed animals
for fun i can tell you that no he looks
like the american psycho did you
immediately fight differently when you
like
when you were you fighting when you had
kids yes so when you had your first kid
you were fighting no no okay no i had
when i was on ultimate fighter jacob was
three years old three and a half and
jonah was two months old and me and matt
were on ultimate together yeah we're on
the show together we're on the ultimate
fighter together and we fought each
other when we're in the ufc yeah who won
that card brenda did caught me a joke i
gave a thumbs up and went right to sleep
oh [ __ ] oh watch in toronto
and we didn't want to fight each other
but the ufc forced to force us too we
were like let's just make a show of it
and then that just was awkward that was
very hard oh well what the [ __ ] that's
got to be cool why i called him i go bro
they just asked me to offer me the fight
he goes me too do i go what the [ __ ] you
want to do and he was like i gotta take
he was like he's like they said that you
were talking all this [ __ ] that you
asked for this fight whenever else and
then i was like they told me the exact
same
exact same thing that's what my friend
does dude when he wants to hang out with
two people he'd be like dude chris said
he wants to hang let's hang and the
other guy will be like dude davidson
wants to hang and then we both show up
and they're like dude you [ __ ]
orchestrated this yeah i didn't even
want to go i didn't want to leave i
thought you wanted to see me [ __ ] this
that's what the ufc did to me that's how
it bonded you guys and yeah that's the
person that's why you do that yeah here
we go guys so what we got here who's
who's winning that's what agents do
that's how they package [ __ ] i think the
other guy's going to win
too much
yeah this guy's ready he's zoned in yeah
yeah i like how he's already like in
defense mode and he's not even in the
middle of the ring yet i like this so
brendan i felt like i'm being 44 years
old i'm way too old to start getting
tattoos and then soon i'm gonna be the
wrinkly old guy with tattoos and i was
like you know what's cool though dude
it can be it can be there are some cool
dudes yeah you you could do it yeah you
could just say this
no he does your thoughts on his neck
yeah eric do you have tattoos no you're
a [ __ ] statue you know that i [ __ ]
get a tattoo at this point in my life
i just got married and i turned 50. yeah
but you could have gotten it he didn't
know if you'd have you but your wife is
younger you know your younger soul yeah
yeah how old your wife she's 33. you're
a [ __ ] stallion i tell you if you
have a model too
she's six nine yeah she's tall as [ __ ]
her whole family her dad dude her dad's
seven foot so i'm trying to have some
nba actually seven feet yeah how tall is
she
she's she's tall she's six foot but
she's
did he play in the nba yeah that's
disappointing if he did yeah but he he
was amateur pro okay he tried an amateur
that's a bummer you're seven foot and
you're working at us at least he got
there though dude i mean some guys are
seven feet and got nowhere yeah imagine
you're seven foot do you know how much
that would [ __ ] suck to try to find
clothing being seven foot tall and not
being professional athletes well hey you
look ridiculous
b what car are you gonna drive and see
how about everybody asks you do you play
sports oh you got him in the ball leave
me alone but here and d you gotta
everyone goes i bet his dick is huge and
even if it's pretty big
it's gonna be small it's big imagine it
on him yeah yeah but the girth that's
coming behind that no matter how big
that's a lot of momentum think of the
weirdest yeah yeah you got all that
torque coming from it's a small dick
energy perspective
it's a lot of torque
don't worry i mean you throw that [ __ ]
into anger yeah yeah
she was bad yeah she was dating shaq and
then they broke up she had a small dick
anyway i was like oh shaq has a small
dick and then you think about it that's
what they said but also dude
but also seven four yeah yeah you know
what sucks that's like the ultimate
thing that's like the only one thing
that every chick can go to yeah he has a
small dick well i tell you what i wish i
had a small dick so when people said
that i'd be like yup and i'd own that
[ __ ] but i don't it's so [ __ ] large
it's ridiculous anyway okay i know it
sucks right okay yeah his his dick so
big is fighting in the next fight
light heavyweight
hey chris will that big dick be in
dallas it's crazy it will be on august
26th chrisley.com because you mentioned
it my very average but grateful dick
will be in baltimore next week i have a
thick head and it'll be in san diego
they can't cool all tattoos though bro
they'd be hidden anyway
the dopest oh but here's the thing back
to you not getting tattoos man yeah
right and i like uh your perspective on
grandpa's you know we're we're not gonna
be grandpa's right we're like great
dance
right you and i have it's not gonna last
you and i have two ten years before we
forget everyone start shooting our pants
in jewelry for sure yeah for sure that's
one of the big that's one of the biggest
reasons
my wife now kayla wants to have kids and
i was like listen ahead of vasectomy
already b
i'm not gonna remember [ __ ] in five
years so like i really got to be careful
about if i bring a kid in uh i won't
know what they have to do yeah
the second reversal
are you worried about it um i was we'd
already seen signs of it
my maternal grandfather uh had uh
alzheimer's my mother i thought had
alzheimer's she does she actually
believe this [ __ ] or not she does she
has alcohol induced dementia oh alcohol
oh yeah so she pickled her brain oh [ __ ]
alcohol will do that yeah yeah yeah
alcohol and fighting to me two big
things yeah oh then definitely don't
play football you're four and also don't
be in baltimore come whatever
next week yeah thursday friday he won't
remember you won't show up
you know he uh you would have signed the
ct already though i'm sure i would i
lost my keys today i'm like here we go
this is a weird thing but i always
forget meryl streep's name i've
remembered it right i have i have i
remember right now some people like that
but sometimes i'm like me too devil
wears prada what do you mean i got two
people like that greatest actress of all
time and it bugs me i start because my
mom has dimensions you wanna call her
maryland you wanna know who mine are
what i don't remember
[Music]
that's how i know i got it
well done
i might have a splash fit every now and
then i know because i can do two weeks
out doing my full hour of stand up and
then just look at the bullet points and
go and rip [ __ ] now half stand up and
not miss a beat and there's no way
sometimes you can't you're saying no
i've never not been able to do that oh
yeah well also that'll that
probably doing that is really good for
your your you know what i mean like yeah
i would be so worried i would forgive my
outline and i would know where to go i
don't know why i don't forget this guy
is better
this one little green shorts guys better
than this
little green guy my god a little short a
little green shorts guys it's all this
mexican is [ __ ] good man yeah well i
don't know their name i would always
forget ryan gosling's name up until i
watched
gray man i was like ryan reynolds i
liked how i liked how he i liked how he
was acting and bro ryan ryan ryan ryan
gosling is a phenomenal actor he really
is oh yeah you know dude
i've never gotten on the rhine really
really even after the
he's mad his face is red he's mad he's
getting hit i'd be mad yeah um and uh
sam rockwell
is like that uh how about this never
mind i got totally obscure sam rockwell
movie i guarantee you guys have never
seen questions and it's absolutely
fantastic
quest is one of my favorite funny bro
gentlemen broncos
no you just made that you guys ever seen
that no that's a good one i i don't i
don't know if i've ever even heard that
one hysterically yeah
i don't know his name but the [ __ ]
older ball didn't what movie chris uh
galaxy quest wait the alien guy who you
know talked about yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah wait galaxy quest yeah isn't that
what johnny drama store to start in
uh in entourage no no no no it's uh tim
allen tim allen sam rockwell weaver
first time i saw sam rockwell was a
galaxy
you know what i'm thinking of i'm
thinking of what's that movie john
travolta did that oh no it's in space
it's like the worst moment of all time
oh my god what's that i know
battlefield earth
dude that is give me my money back
the hair
yes no wait who's the go to go to go to
battle or um what's the one uh [ __ ]
god damn it galaxy quest go down i'm
gonna let you guys know general broncos
is [ __ ] outside you guys should watch
it eric you've never seen gentlemen
broncos no
so you're saying i'm one up on you right
now yeah you did uh
these guys don't get your feelings hurt
eric justin
no no
go more what's that word oh you could
have just hit go back go back
advertising whatever that word is yes go
back
that guy is [ __ ] hilarious yeah he's
like
[Music]
yeah
but he did it so weird yeah what a
choice it was so weird that was a that
is a [ __ ] phenomenon it's so funny
that's one of my top movies that that
movie for me is my head's not weird at
all it's like that jack black movie um
school of rock oh great i do i never get
into school rock dude
watch it with your kids school of rock
jack black is jack bike at his best bro
jack black is so legend funny bro dude
this is the movie okay i got to watch it
oh
school of rock what am i not getting
into it because it's awesome
he's actually he's really funny he's
like side splitting one thing how about
his mom jack pack's mom [ __ ] nasty
scientists who helped [ __ ] right yeah
she like helped save like the the
discovery i like space shuttle i started
gaming because of him i realized you
could do that because he was doing it
jack black yeah jack black is a huge
gamer he was getting like a million
followers those [ __ ] instagram videos
he does with his uh
you know what's funny to me is like
[Music]
yeah he's trying to get in there so he
can't get up oh yeah but you know what's
finding me with like instagram when like
real like talented celebrities like oh
i should pay attention to this like will
smith yeah and then you have people that
have whatever 20 million followers and
you see their contents yeah yeah but
then when an actual talented person goes
like jackpots put effort into this like
jack black or will smith they blow
people of the [ __ ] water i know well
they also have [ __ ] a lot of money to
make the content what else does he value
my point
what else is he doing he's good at will
smith had a team yeah uh yeah he was
like drones and [ __ ] he's on epcot
standard yeah yeah dude my two openers
derek posted nassan wrote for him he had
a
10 10 man team that did his instagram oh
wow people team assan did that yeah and
derek yeah that sounds like such a yeah
i know i know why why not why not do you
also retire
do you guys feel pressure of like i
always have to have posted content all
the [ __ ] time
like i feel like that would become so
overwhelming i would just i would it
would frustrate me to no end by the way
mourinho is aggressive by the way um
he's he's doing a good job of mixing up
his strikes but none of them are landing
there's
nobody's done anything that's been
overwhelming to me so far
but mourinho's trying right yeah he's
aggressor here yeah
ooh i feel like he's winning the fight
it's hard it's hard for an aggressive
puncher to fight a counter puncher
especially when the counter punches
being passive i think that's really
difficult to do i think this guy's good
that was gonna be your next point wasn't
it chris yeah i was yeah but you took it
right out of my mouth [ __ ] it
because you get sick of all the
promotions this guy's he just salsa
don't you but you really don't like it
yeah no i i do if i'm gonna do something
funny it's gonna be me talking on the
camera yeah i don't want to put any
editing involved with it
yeah are you are you written funny or
are you off the cuff funny i never write
yeah never
like you know you're not one of the guys
like every sunday i have to do it i go i
work it out on stage and then if it's
good i'll remember it really you got a
memory like that
yeah so far
but he does so many spots and i've been
doing it for a long time oh yeah yeah
yeah how many days how many days a week
do you stand up at least three yeah yeah
at least multiple sets but but before
but before you were born
there's multiple shows and you do one
like that's why la's great and similar
to new york you can do two sets of the
improv
store ice house open your b-line that
you know you know before um the pandemic
i would do like six shows a week this
guy's dancing or six nights i would do
two in one night yeah but then i'm like
i know i had a kid i'm like i could work
some kid mixes i can work smarter yeah i
just didn't so girl told me that he was
like he was like you you're new to it so
do spots yeah he's like you know make
sure he's not missing time with your
family bert's back out he's been at the
comedy store doing like bert christian
friends yeah burt has yeah in the belly
because he's trying to work on a new
hour interesting
they do a lot of podcasts together don't
they yeah
so wait bert is working a new hour to do
uh a special or something i i was
talking to um
jessie nick the other day and he's like
i may never do it uh another special
again he's like [ __ ] it he said there's
no money in it i know because he was
like he was like i had whatever he said
four specials yeah and he goes i get it
he's like and then now i get the
offerings like i'm not going to waste my
i get it i guess i'm not going to waste
my material on this i know because you
can keep making so much [ __ ] money on
the road it's like but then also i i
agree with him like we had the same talk
at the improv because he did shopping
friends and he was like the specials
just they're not the same anymore he's
like you burn him and how many people
were watching him i don't know he's like
millions depends yeah he was like for me
it was millions yep
but he was like
um
you know the offer is just not the same
where it was trending towards oh i'm i'm
going to keep doing special i'm making
so much money now there's no upside to
it but that's why i think youtube's big
it's big but you're not going to make
real money but you're going to make the
money on the road on the on the tickets
i got what you're saying so is that is
that where money comes in from from the
tickets or money coming from merchandise
tickets merge
tickets if if you're if you're a big
actor you can't beat your tickets i mean
tickets are the thing like if you're
doing theaters
big theaters
or you can go to clubs like la jolla
yeah true 9th 10th and 11th in september
um
yeah
yeah it's interesting though but merch
it depends on who you are like you know
i like i love i love i i like doing
merch so like you know it's fun for me
so because i think of my energy behind
it i do well with it um but if you're
just a con like a lot of comics are just
like [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] about
it dude i would or i'm gonna do it just
like uh everyone does much i'm gonna do
much right right right why do it oh wow
what a sweet you know i would never oh
my god um that's a hell of an armbar
attempt from the jump uh i would never
do merch i never did do march because
i'm so afraid it's going to end up on
the clearance rack somewhere and i'll be
like what the [ __ ] it does i'm sure you
think right tj maxx yeah
we have plenty of those in west
lafayette it's okay that second oh he's
inside out of his eyes they're gonna end
it they're gonna no they will fight oh
[ __ ] yeah
i'm up here oh [ __ ] what does mourinho
do hold on oh [ __ ] that could hurt would
have been amazing oh that would have
been amazing but that was smart
off he's smart he look at him he's like
cleaning himself up clean yourself up he
was doing that anyway though that's kind
of his thing nobody's like i gotta clean
myself up
this is a really i'm surprised at how
this fight is going
this guy's got the advantage now
we see the difference there between this
than the heavyweight fight like yeah
you're getting that's a good hook
i love that uh straight lunging hook if
you get a move back from the straight i
love that straight this game is it weird
how all the commentators are bald this
guy moves a lot it is weird
you know what i always felt that uh
what's um
not joe not cormier
john anderson i always thought he looked
like squidward
from spongebob people said that about me
i feel that you get a spot you really
did strike a nerve there it's okay i
don't see it that ridiculous
thing right now it's like when you when
you're sitting there like now it just
i'm ready for that [ __ ] which i'm
looking for um hey can we get a take on
kyle's uh bucket hat are we feeling it
or not [ __ ] bucket hats man hey listen
if you cut the top out of that and let
your wig pop out i'm really impressed
with gilligan over there you could get
uh [ __ ] gilligan you're forgetting to
bring it all right would you smash
marianne or ginger
i gotta look at him again man i think
marianne's the one you bring home ginger
remember
i'm too young
kill again
[Music]
that's ginger all day long
yeah well that picture yeah but yeah
yeah
ooh the guy in the middle bro we have
the same jeans on the middle is kyle
wow dude that's gilligan [ __ ] ginger
was it there's there's marianne right
here i like how chin's like that's
killing me i'm sorry marianne
another underrated movie is mars attacks
no that that people like that movie
tom jones in that [ __ ] he is jack black
tom jones in that movie holy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
dude mourinho is so aggressive on this
and they're yeah and you know what's
interesting
counter kicks
moreno throws his jab long as a
[ __ ] he throws long punches for
his body he's got the thing about
mourinho as he throws jabs longer than a
[ __ ] yeah we'll be right back
sponsored by you know also what but it
hurts a minute but also helps them
moreno's help the length on his jab is
that he oversteps his lead foot so much
and how he's straightened his leg out
you see that oh you're technical huh
yeah wow that's the kind of [ __ ] i like
to hear about yeah but that's the reason
why that that his his jab is so long his
punches are so long he can fight from a
long distance but he hyper extends
that's why he gets his lead leg taken
out oh it's already happened twice so
far oh man also when he extends like
that's hard for me this guy's a
ballerina yeah
that was a great spin movie
to recover great
but he's got this guy he's like
like who throws elbows from space he
just fixed his hair that was great
don't have to fix their hair
they have the lego helmet that natural
gel that manscape in jail they probably
so there's no stopping a ufc fight with
because of all this blood no that's not
true unless it runs into his eye yeah or
it's just in the eye they'll stop it i
believe didn't joe joe rogan use the
expression a goat's vagina
oh wow uh someone's big cut yeah he's
like geez it's like a goat's vagina you
said that live on air yeah not when it
was disney well you could say vagina not
one was owned by disney oh kids right in
the nuts baby we didn't stop i was at a
body shop that's a body shot
oh that was the body shot it's done that
was a liver shot was it oh wow
what a comeback what an attack wow
now he's gonna have to fight figarita
that's a hell of a cut right there i'd
say i i picked that well i thought he
got hit in the nuts that must have been
it looked like the inside of the thigh
to me yeah i thought well it was hard to
tell but unless he [ __ ] his knee up
eric let's do this
let me drop one low kick on you today no
no what are you what are you does let me
jump one listen i feel like you need to
know this yeah i feel like you know you
know that say let's do this i want you
to say like hey let's go to the movies
or let's let's go to the movies yeah
that's it yeah yeah crazy
bam we just saw a grey i'll do with
chris too let me drop one look just so
you know the sensation
you don't think i've had it i've had it
done this looks crazy now
now there was there was a like uh uh
like a journalist or something let force
griffin kicked him in the leg and he
broke the kid's leg i can i can imagine
wouldn't have to throw that out you can
do it afterwards you probably dislocate
i'll i'll i'll i'll i'll i'll barely see
you know that's sweet i love that
i'm done with you yeah okay
me and you done eric's like it's not
happening
[Laughter]
that's the one that just barely beaten
mourinho can we can we actually do that
can we watch that fight and then chris
and i will do the comments no we don't
like where you guys we don't want to be
so stressed there it is yeah
let's see oh yeah here it is
where's the kick
oh no that's not oh that was a belly
kill
oh wow and the guy almost started to cry
dude
really terrible so who's going to let me
demonstrate i won't even hurt you i just
wanted you guys to learn something here
it is again i want you guys to learn the
game boom oh wow not low at all
i didn't like him i didn't like him at
the time i like him now but i was so
pissed that i was trying to fight it off
and i was like it hurts real bad yeah
okay i got a dick's name there's nothing
you can do i feel like that when you
were fighting you went to a different
place in your head me yeah no i'm
exactly the same person you know you did
you said you didn't like like okay you
didn't make yourself
say hate this person or no or
what was it
true warrior
has no emotion yes yeah yeah well
[ __ ] god i hear where you're coming
from today
fighting was just it was something i
didn't like doing so it was just
interesting let's just go jesus christ
let's go get i hated it too it was just
an athletic competition yeah
i was like this is so violent but there
are guys that [ __ ] love it yeah yeah
yeah
they're serious they've got some [ __ ]
dude
if you really enjoy fighting and hurting
people like that you've got some [ __ ]
names some guys who love you who loves a
tank abbott
well i heard
there are guys now that like it there's
some guys i mean sure you can say they
like it like i mean and some people
might think they do and then they'll be
like man what the [ __ ] was i doing for
so long i wonder what that guy's
thinking back there i would do
interviews then like how do you feel i'm
like i'm terrified like okay cut uh so
let's not do that that's not gonna sell
the fight you're probably never prepared
for a hit right
like no matter how you train like that
guy got that hit and his body just
collapsed i mean i don't care how you
train it doesn't matter you're not ready
not for a body shot but you there's one
thing you can do to help with that and
that's happy hippocratum just listen oh
really i use kratom kai kara france
should use kratom i think bran moreno's
on kratom but listen kratom is my
miracle pill i do it when i do stand up
i'm on it right now all right basically
have an iv of kratom but i only trust
one brand one brand owner
that's happy zippo oh wow that's right
dude and listen kratom used to be like
cbd was the wild west can't trust
anybody and then happy hippo said hold
our pills we got you daddy visit happy
hippo herbals herbals.com use promo code
thickboy that's 20 off for life use that
code as many times as you want visit
happyhippoherbles.com use promo code
stickboy254life
it's funny you say life because life you
travel a lot of different places
and i'll be in dallas on august 26th
uh at the uh texas trustee youth theater
literally the worst segue i've ever
heard
crazy like that so you go to
chrisley.com yeah yeah and uh you get
tickets
check out the king sing the wing and the
sing that's a pretty good podcast
and then could be in baltimore or
chicago and i just got married and shout
out to my beautiful wife oh now we all
got rachel griffin love you
shout out to my beautiful wife oh no
rachel's sweet
[Laughter]
that builds that fight up even though
they have to they're moving was this a
championship fight yes
because the champions are hurt i'm about
to say you won the intercontinental
championship and i'm surprised they
don't bring figuerito into the those
were always they were the best fights in
the wwe
right now hey so why do they do an
interim bill i figured as a champ is he
hurt yeah he got hurt is this the guy
he's a real champion and he's a
[ __ ] but brandon moreno beat the
[ __ ] on him the first time second time
was close and then he couldn't fight so
the guy looks blind blind with his
suitcases just guessing sweater no he
looks like
i'm going to wear that sweater in
baltimore next thursday friday saturday
it's not his huh he doesn't deserve it
oh look at this
and he's big for the weight class too
this guy in the red
yes he's thick little cookie wait wait
what is that on there a panther what's
on it that's a panther and i'm not mad
at it now i probably want to wear it
right
see oh wow look at him hold on
hey i'm going to start scrapping if you
bring somebody in like that and be like
hey dude it's my time it's his time bro
hey can we talk about the i would just
tell him is you're very very rude yeah
no doubt can we talk can we talk about
the giant cameraman in the back that's
gonna be me in four years if this
podcast doesn't work you you've pointed
yourself out can you wear that sweater
look at his lump on his head yeah that's
for real that's oh wow he's not a dumas
that's just like joe rogan is coming out
of his head
no it's quite quad or radar from uh
so these guys are going to fight next
yes and they fought twice before and
it's one in one
ah
once brazilian one is mexican we have
some
offshore
violence yeah but this guy's probably
telling him like that's not a real belt
dude that's what he's talking about look
but there's respect they have great
fights they're really they're two of the
best by far oh that's cool
you just brought up quade hey don't put
your arm around me don't sign me
wow that that's brendan in five years
yeah yeah
if i keep
arnold's name is quaid
oh no i'm talking about queen i don't
know about you guys you're talking about
the baby yeah the guy's kind of saying
i'm saying it's coming out of his head
the [ __ ] cueto the baby things come
out of his head with the lump now you
get the reference i thought you said man
and [ __ ]
look at that pink suit i will say this
though it's like
he could have better jeans on you know
what i mean i mean he's got [ __ ]
blanket is that a bear or black panther
what does this say you're gonna have
like all that bling on your that's a lot
of you know who makes that that's a
gucci and black cat firecrackers to
collab
right there really you know i made that
up black cat's a very famous firebrand
i respect that
matt thought it was real he got it
hey what's uh
what's what's his name what's uh marty
gonna do
kamaru's one yeah what's his role going
to be do you know oh i didn't fight the
big fight yeah that's a pretty big they
fought uh twice before it's a real it's
over like they don't get blood on my
gucci my my whatever the hell that is
wow don't believe me buddy
wow
that's a huge win for bram rhino that is
man he was in a hell of a position too
wait wait for him to come out to get a
finish over [ __ ] france is insane
do it
liver kicks liver shots what little i
know of this i saw just from watching i
felt like this guy was going to win the
fight it looked like yeah he was the
aggressor like he's fighting whisperer
yeah
and he yeah we got to call eric to see
who's going to win so we could bet
so eric i wouldn't want him hugging me
just getting a nice pink suit on just
now just now yeah
flashback fights
i've done two shows with him now yeah i
saw all his losses it was hilarious yeah
tough to do yeah but right but but
hearing him hear him talk about it then
we then we did a thing about patty i i
uh educated him on like patty pam and
then just watching all the fights before
he got to ufc and then i watched that
fight the other week yeah and i was like
just i'm fascinated by it now so that's
why i'm here he texts me with during
patty's fighting dude this guy's [ __ ]
good
he's an aggressive kid man yeah strikes
well he's well-rounded he's had a hell
of a personality i feel like he i feel
like he prepared like i felt like he
really prepared for that fight
you know
like he knew what this guy was going to
do and he was ready for it yeah he beat
him at his own
thing you know this movie looks terrible
yeah oh bro the lion
this is cujo no look i don't but black
people do [ __ ] better
i don't
no no this is lion king too yeah no look
don't you remember you don't know what
kujo was i don't know
i do not hate a movie like this right
now but it is insane that you just elba
is doing it
he he needs money right no
problem he took a kiss dude this guy's
like uh what's he called like samuel
jackson did you say he just
[ __ ] in every he just he likes
money the show no people like money no i
love it i love that i make the money but
it's just like
i don't know it's just because you know
what you have to ask yourself you have
to see who the producers are
and if he's one of the producers then it
makes sense or the director big time
director no no no no i feel like it's
like yeah no you know if they're going
to plus 1300 today no no no
that's if you uh the same game
parliament so if you you could parliame
oh
yeah that's big because just to watch
him like you know
am i going to be lazy
um by the way
it's a [ __ ] great time apart
really yeah she's a great time and i'm
really pretty in real life too laughter
in real life yeah she's really good but
here's the thing though like and she's
cool as [ __ ] yeah so here's the thing
though like you'd be hitting a face a
lot you'd be you she wouldn't look like
that like you would flatten her nose out
right so
does that mean she hasn't taken a lot of
punches or or the the punch she took
weren't significant yeah but i'll tell
you what she's [ __ ] dope i partied
with her in vegas are you saying the
person
hits like a girl or whatever
you just got canceled
um dude nunez she's ready is nuna's
gonna win
no uh you know what i feel i feel you're
right oh you think no i feel like peyton
is going to do it again oh wow and so
she's such she's so [ __ ] good i feel
like she's on top of her game they
fought before yeah and pena won and she
was a huge underdog oh yeah yeah i
remember that
[Music]
oh she got her with that yeah looking
for huh but you gotta like it's hard man
like once you start making a lot of
money and you came from nothing and all
of a sudden you got to keep finding that
the grind it's like you know what you
know i think you know i think of when i
think about fighters
i think of eminem
and the reason i think of eminem is
because his first album came out and he
[ __ ] crushed it was so much angst and
animosity whatever else right and then
all of a sudden he made so much money he
came so he got so many accolades so
quick and then he tried to keep the
angst but he didn't have the yanks
anymore so by the time he came out with
his third album he didn't have that
anymore right and that's like these guys
so they they're pissed off they have
nothing they're grinders and also by the
time you had money for three or four uh
title fights or or or or uh you know
retentions yeah now you're like dude is
the hunger really there anymore so you
don't have it now you try to act like
you saw the angst of the animosity but
you don't anymore and i think that
that's what makes gsb great like floyd
mayweather they stayed on top of their
game yeah they just they get better yeah
even though they have all these i
actually think it was different i think
eminem's thing was that he had to come
up with another hit every time and he
didn't want to do that yes they wanted
they wanted that he wanted to he they
wanted him to make that like a pop
number one hit slim shady yeah that's
what that's that was the pressure that
he had every single time
i've actually heard him say that
lyrically he's such a different animal
that i feel like whatever he wanted to
put pen to as long as he as long as he
like the either a the machine got behind
it or b the crowd got behind it the dude
had
if you think about all of his records
there's that one hit you know not here
have you heard his diss on the machine
gun kelly yeah
first of all i thought mgk's uh diss
track went harder than that by the way
not the rebuttal uh eminem's rebuttal
was [ __ ]
listen to it again how was this did you
know eminem has a half brother that's a
rapper and he [ __ ] kills it too no
his name's nf bruce and he's a [ __ ]
christian rapper and they don't know
each other and they just found out did
you hear the [ __ ] nugget i just
dropped ready to rumble eminem's half
brother is a [ __ ] christian rapper
and he doesn't cuss i mean [ __ ] kills
it his name is does he look like him uh
the boy you know you know what else i
know you know him
you know what's nuts about nf is he used
as manscape dude
he was really hairy and i'm glad you uh
please be cool eric let's take a little
break because nf uses manscape and i
have
there's an alarm for manscape because
the product alert here uh you asked for
it they listened my friends at manscape
just brought back the ultra smooth
package and nf is using it that's right
everyone knows by now that the lawnmower
4.0 or 4.0
yes dude lawn mower 4.0 electric shaver
for your balls there's nothing better
man it's time to shave that bush of
yours and get right to the root with a
discount code just for my friends out
there you hairy fellas get 20 off and
free shipping at manscape.com use promo
code cfc this package they got it all
you get the lawnmower 4.0 you get the
crop exfoliator crop gel when it's time
to shave the crop shaver daddy it's time
to get up close and personal with the
best tools for the job the ultra smooth
package from manscape get 20 off and
free shipping with the code cfc
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code cfc manscape.com
smooth out your fellas with the relaunch
ultra smooth package from the fellas at
manscape your balls will thank you i
like how she's like wearing headphones
like i'm going to do i know she's
listening to my podcast
no no you know what she is and i like
where your head's at because she goes
she said this she goes uh actually what
gave me the motivation is king to sting
the wing in the sink
she's right now
you know what she's posted more times
than theo
the [ __ ]
every time you do that
i think she's been on king and a sting
more times then
[Laughter]
i walked out christian didn't hear it
headphones on and they were actually um
steve aoki's second pair of headphones
he ever made oh [ __ ] paris steve mayo
what are those what's a sausage
uh oh that's a brat daddy that's a burnt
brat nothing better please save me one i
love them [ __ ] love it yeah dude
everyone eats and then i get done i'm
like sorry bro it's gone yeah yeah the
steaks are gone yeah sorry about that
maybe they saved you making all this
landscape money i only say this much
they [ __ ] cook those steaks really
well today yeah they did bite them
massively good but maybe there's on that
green mountain grill mike is a master
chef whatever it was green mountain yeah
there you go mike is
you know
i trust thanks dude is it cool if i just
deep thought this thing or yeah thanks
man oh it's warm daddy oh these are
fresh off the grill oh oh you've got i
don't think i like you i mean you're
holding on eddie yeah come on no hold on
i'm with you i'm already with you yeah
you are this mr [ __ ] carnivore diet i
know not to put it on because i'm a good
friend because i listen to it
but when yours comes in looking all
[ __ ] sweet i know can i get some
mustard on a bun with a thing please
eating
what the hell is mark doing is he just
over there [ __ ] combing his hair what
are you doing out there i'm going pena i
get this i'm going peggy the second
round i see i think pena third or fourth
but i think amanda nunes come out like a
banshee in the first round this is their
second fight or third fight second fight
and if uh pena can weather the storm
she's gonna win but amanda newest has to
get down the first round because i don't
think she wants to do it anymore
all right this is gonna be this i think
it's a first rounder this is a first
rounder hey will someone will someone
just bring me a bun with mustard all
over it
[Laughter]
it's too good bro it's too good it looks
too good
baseball game fellas yeah man take me
out to the ball game i'll tell you what
you're a lot more handsome when you
don't sing
[Laughter]
you know what's funny is there can sing
both of them can sing hey i was in glee
club when i was a kid someone hears
these pipes [ __ ] ready buddy
club hey when i do karaoke what's your
song what's your song when you do
karaoke
come on give me
i don't do karaoke i don't [ __ ] around
ever ever you don't do karaoke at all if
i do it's journey
justin
girl
i'm purple right
it's too hard to now a whole song it's
just too hard it's too long you don't do
it right
thank you are you kidding me i go in my
friend oh i'll i'll do uh backstage
thanks bro
never going again never going to get it
now we're going to get it
on your black jeans hey listen at least
you got nice blue stripes on your socks
that's what really matters
well i saw those bits those are old
school sizes oh i saw those earlier by
the way look you guys ever seen that
thing about lacroix how they just try to
figure out how they have the worst
tasting water of all time i don't know
why i have lacroix in here yeah
do you really yeah you're such a
pretentious do you like soda it's just
fancy dude i do but i don't drink it so
i drink this [ __ ] so i don't have to so
your water tea coffee water coffee
that's it okay that's it you know you
have you had it it's milk what does it
have your california soy milk
i saw one
documentary about how milk is made and i
was out from a cow he come out they're
just what they do and that's why you
stop drinking it what do they do do they
melt the cow do you want to know how
they make that broth you're eating right
now well they do
how about you
i don't talk about that again i'm not
there yet
what the [ __ ]
yeah
oh man
when they just cry from their teeth
it just oozes out no seriously what they
do to get the milk out i don't drink
milk anyway no it's just like first of
all you know they understand they
have to be pregnant what
yeah they have to be pregnant
no they don't oh why
yeah no no that's not true i don't think
that's true this guy you're talking like
you [ __ ] know i know for a fact and
just you don't know
yeah this guy's like he's a [ __ ] like
he's
white i live in indiana and i believe
that this is
bring up an
cows have to be pregnant to produce milk
because here's the answer
no
that's insane what's not
well maybe the bull cows have to be
pregnant they don't identify very well
cows only produce milk after they have
given birth they don't have to think
they're they're they're pregnant though
no no
you said they had to think they're
pregnant yeah but that's what i'm saying
it's like they they have to spend your
your time framing no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no there's
bruce milk dairy gavin need to be uh
pregnant
all right yeah oh so you saw one
documentary my bad it's like this
[ __ ] guy the way he said it like i
know he's convincing though right no not
to me bro never convince him
i i also i know this [ __ ] is
like no not you're not true and i'm like
this i know because of the the
confidence that you were using too much
it was too much
and i [ __ ] felt it i know i [ __ ] up
i mean wow that's insane so they they
they impregnate them and then they milk
them and then they just keep on going
like a wet nurse there's wet nurses
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i appreciate that oh dude on my flight
today i must have farted 30 years got
your nose you might as well got your
just brutal it was terrible you ever
fart while you're fighting
i don't think so no that's a good thing
it's a hard-hitting question tim sylvia
[ __ ] himself yeah he did you guys have
[ __ ]
he did [ __ ] but like from this far away
you tap out that's she's a she's a 215
dog wow
serious swiss after being there i'm
going for painting i want her to win
let's go girl i'm going for babies
better for the years
and she's [ __ ] dope too he's too
serious actually you know what the other
chick's really cool too though i can't i
can't i can't just i don't know amanda a
man
uh lacroix what is it
whatever this
water
is
but if you like this [ __ ] have you
tried uh stevias
really the cream soda
[ __ ] cream soda i don't like that [ __ ]
uh the guy who the guy who uh owns or is
a ceo this guy's facial hair is
fantastic fantastic yeah he's good yeah
what's fantastic well bruce buffer for
the main event no no the the the referee
or whoever that guy is he had like oh
that's mike beltran yeah he had to tuck
his goatee in
his
nipples passes
and they made him tuck him in because it
was a distraction yep
guys would use it and choke the blood
that's stupid tap tap um you don't like
it
real quick
so i don't drink it
mexican coke so i don't drink it what's
wrong with diet coke i don't drink uh
anything like that what's wrong with
that though
uh cancer
you'll die that's not true
yeah you're doing the cow thing no i'm
not no see i'll see that's different i
went that's not true yeah yeah that's
why i've already called you out now
you're trying to like you know what i
mean
you're trying to gain back some footing
yeah yeah and it's not going to work you
are a know-it-all
and what that means is you don't know
that how does she always face back does
she always face the case they don't know
it all that's what i'm saying don't know
that's what i'm saying i don't know i'm
not
know it some
don't know it you're i don't
no she always does i didn't know she did
that yeah what she turns around right
when it's finished oh that's her wife
right to the right yeah and she turns
around like this had a kid too right
yeah he's just a mario tattoo on a cap
too no oh wow you got no boots
[Laughter]
none of that but you you wouldn't have a
booty if you're doing this much cardio
right that's true that's someone but
you've seen rachel ostervich
oh she's a booty really
okay she fights yeah oh yeah with all
that
she does nothing she does bare knuckle
fighting he's fighting ufc
okay okay but i don't know what i'm
talking about i'm gonna know it all no
no no no no i'm gonna know it all she's
gonna lift it up
um i would never do bare knuckle no
absolutely excuse me if there was ever a
guy who's gonna do it dude this guy's
hands yeah
yeah i was gonna say that
he just picked your brush
you're gonna hit with a [ __ ] brillo
better
the only dude i know that cleans carpets
with his knuckles
it looked like
buffer and the ref were doing that that
you know that comedy thing where you're
like
oh yeah yeah they do that no no i don't
know why i put the thing under the yeah
yeah i've thought about that in a long
time hey she comes off on fire um
amanda nunes comes out like a [ __ ]
venezuelan vixen yes
uh-huh
or is that what you call her mm-hmm
that's her nickname
i made it up
uh amanda this has mad knockout power
for chicks yeah mad knockout she will
knock out brian callum right now yeah
well until rink said he'll get his
feelings hurt
here you go you think
wow you know so she has a mario
sorry what do you say mario mario say
mario great game you say i italian
no no i should though director italian
my grandma would used to do that
um and uh
that would be to get kicked by a [ __ ]
mario face
is just so disrespectful and then when
you kick you say it's a me mario
[Laughter]
yeah it's also a tattoo it looks like
he's punching through the coin right
yeah yeah yeah it's very i feel like
just i feel like those knee kicks should
be illegal because that's just trying to
maim people is calvin watching hi calvin
hi kristen
are they watching yeah i think they are
i don't know calvin probably [ __ ]
running around not watching but probably
saw you once it was like dad you know
yeah i was like all right
she's got mario on her a calf buddy
he loves mario oh [ __ ] the way i
looked i look over he got a
just get it get after it that's the
worst too man like when you know it's a
five round fight you don't want to get
into it early because you want to save
your energy yeah and so you just wonder
what happens so long and they've already
fought so they kind of got a sense of
like i thought man the noodles would
come out a little more i feel like one
hit from either one of them and this is
going to be oh that was powerful here
they go now we got some action dude she
was throwing some long punches there
kept her chin up a little bit that's a
quick night though huh yeah dude it's
been scooting along nice yeah i feel
like every time we do it it's like
freaking 1am by the time we get out of
here
it's late
i don't know also somehow it feels
longer when brian's here
that's probably good what time is your
center 9 45 yeah absolutely not i'm not
gonna make it if you left right now you
could maybe make it any that'd be tight
on time i'm gonna tell i'm gonna be late
man if i was a if i was dana white i
would just i'd eat bratwurst and watch
fights it's weird it's weird that like
those that land right behind the ear are
the ones that really do uh the damage
because of your equilibrium gets thrown
off you're
a little bit dizzy
there's something wrong with that girl's
medulla oblongata
yeah they're really uh feeling each
other out
normally that's a sexy thing in a chick
fight but no it's just boring do you
think it's sexy uh when they feel each
other oh oh oh oh that kind of fight
sorry
oh that was a great good job man little
baby hook there
and amanda recently got married right
yeah lydia and they have a kid yeah a
baby girl you know but when if if
julianna pena loses at least she's like
at least i'm still [ __ ] hot right
like she has everything else oh she got
rocked yeah
i feel like a man who should rush her
right now
oh
that's it yeah my man is kind of [ __ ]
her up wait what happened she got i
think she got checked oh really i didn't
see that yeah she's a little she's a
little all over it yeah she's a little
wobbly right who's wobbly which one
yeah
okay
who's the one that's like
the the what and this is bad for july
opinion because man and nuna is gaining
confidence yeah and if she is mentally
weak this is in health yeah
yeah and that was the best bratwurst
i've had in my life
oh got her
did she get her again yeah get her right
she just tripped yeah with her knees
it's so strange that nunez is being so
delicate right now well she's letting
her come in and she's being aggressive
and she's attacking her
well i mean after expensive she knocked
her down twice hit her with that clipped
her twice i figured she'd be a little
more aggressive coming in but maybe
she's gun shy about that i feel like
this is gonna be a first-round thing
yeah yeah if keeps going
you might make your set
just kidding
she can't really find much to do because
when she just fire she gets hit uh-huh
now she's getting [ __ ] she's not
painting this guy she don't want to get
hit either though no one wants to get in
yeah yeah
and i wonder if uh oh [ __ ] okay she
landed there that was a good straight
and i feel like i mean
we got ourselves some fancy cows oh here
we go
let's make it this makes you want to
know better going forward
you're better
she pushes that jab she doesn't throw it
she pushes it though but she does good
on range
but isn't that just to keep her keep her
away isn't that funny
yeah i want to see when somebody throws
a jab i want to pop in the jab right uh
but she's not she's more pushing it
which is good as a lever to keep her
away like at distance but it doesn't do
anything good for her as far as oh my
god great strength bust their nose
hey hershey you know she's smelling nice
hey she has to stay away from that power
get your [ __ ] chin up
six what are you saying chin uh oh yeah
she's not you're sorry julia jonah was
throwing with her chin up and that's all
that's all uh nunez wants oh
good round oh that was that was the best
round i've seen so far the whole night
amanda that's very i like all right
i like how they both like she went to
her i mean she held knocked her down
twice the other one's menacing wobbled
her
yeah
wow calvin was watching and now he's
saying let's watch mario dominos he
watches dominoes and [ __ ] like our
youtube videos domino's going down how
people play dominoes yeah he just
watches you grow up in the pj no no no
no not play dominoes just like the
dominant
bro you ever look at some of those kid
videos on youtube it's like 75 million
oh i know yes cause that's who's
watching [ __ ] they're making how much
money those parents just horn their kids
out
that one kid that the
asian family i can't stand him i don't
know i can't stand a little [ __ ] dude
you're talking what's his name jim
what's that [ __ ] kid's name remember
i brought him up before i went hard on
painting somewhere the the main [ __ ]
kid on youtube
asian kid now you're just ryan ryan yeah
yeah ryan's worth it
[ __ ] but he's got a show on what's it
called
oh wow look at her face
where are you gonna say he gets what he
gets views from opening things right
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he was
the newest toy and they [ __ ] sent him
100 million views 100 million meanwhile
i'm sucking [ __ ] over here wait a minute
that has nothing to do with views you
just do that
in the meantime i'm over here sucking
[ __ ] for fun
wait what's up i'm sweating my ass off
in baltimore all right yeah yeah yeah
meanwhile i'm sucking [ __ ] sometimes
[Laughter]
my whole act out was gonna be [ __ ]
hilarious
what landed though and it's passed right
it's my punchline and then the [ __ ] yeah
she got knocked down and [ __ ]
up get on your bike start moving around
don't say don't experience well i think
she heard your bit coming and she was
like you know what oh we gotta get her
down yeah enough
dude don't engage again right now get
get the cobwebs out
what the [ __ ] what's this
breathe that one
i got this
no that's a charlie brown kick yeah yeah
not good
wait what's the charlie brown song oh
don't [ __ ] do it oh my god jesus why
didn't she come in you said don't do
that you knew it well oh well yeah you
know what that was she was like i don't
know that was
my favorite thing is the legs when
they're on the ground god why would you
julian pena is not having a good night
she still looks good though she's not
like yeah she's still gonna never leave
okay no no but i'm saying like she's not
no i think that she's tripped more than
she got i think i think she's
she [ __ ] with the ball she got [ __ ]
yoked you know what i think man yeah i
think the first fight now that i'm
seeing this play out like this i think
the first fight man
i didn't train very hard to light her up
she beat her in a minute okay i'm back
but yeah and you're you [ __ ] with the oh
yeah
yeah you've got the brazilian horns yeah
you're drunk though right because you're
saying amanda news oh my god keep your
[ __ ] chin down julian i said nunes
bro oh come on
now let's go back on ryan cause i can't
stand him that little kid ryan listen
he's older now all right what was the
joke i was going to do he opens toys
while i'm cycling
yeah i like that joke
he gets 100 million views they send him
to the toys makes [ __ ] millions
in the meantime i'm sucking dick
everyone's like you're doing what come
out of the closet
you know that's the thing man you can't
so that's so that's called the shift
step right so what juliana payne is
doing is called a shift step she throws
multiple punches in a row and switches
her stance from left to right to left to
right and she goes forward yeah no no
pain yeah okay
so what you're doing so let's go to the
shift step right so what she's doing
she's walking forwards through throwing
punches right yeah and it's an
aggressive position and it's fine it's
fun to do that but as long as you keep
your head down and as long as you know
where you're at yeah you can't throw
that [ __ ] with your chin up and come
straight into it [ __ ] strong so why
is she doing that because she's tired
and winded or she just she has to know
she's trying to close distance and she's
getting frustrated because she's in
frustration she's getting lit up yeah
she's got this okay yeah okay okay
nothing she's doing is working right now
so she's trying to force the issue she's
she's a square peg into a round hole
sure sure okay that makes sense yeah and
so for her she's throwing her forehead
but juliana's uh uh uh what's her name
is a [ __ ] gangster of a striker right
yeah she hit so hard yeah damn it it
certainly looks like it i mean
also
pina is getting some shots in there
though well
she's like she's hell on the ground
she's really good
she's really good got it yeah so that's
why she's probably trying to get her
rushed up against the wall amanda
quicker and when she hits it counts yeah
it's hurting her oh that's it i mean
that was that was of a jab wasn't it
jesus christ
but she was stepping into it but she's
not like out it's like her knees are
like ah let's take a break pena is
taking these yeah remember remember how
struvius you get hit and fall false drew
would fall so bad well that's because
he's some foot right yeah
like bambi on ice he would get well you
just hit his legs right he got hit in
the legs he's like so big dude
another charlie brown dancing yeah that
was like you know that was a great move
she just farted
ah that goes
oh that makes me that check hook makes
me nervous
yeah
like she she's like shooting the back
leg almost this one doesn't what's her
face doesn't kick a lot huh nunez she
doesn't kick oh geez that that was going
to hurt her face okay elbow
yeah
look at me that's too smiling having fun
yeah this is like targeting you never do
it
you're in a for a long night when a man
nunez is yeah having a good time oh god
oh
god i know she keeps she's so fluid
right now too oh
i hope she doesn't hear that anderson
silva
dude i'm grappling my ass off yeah if
left let me get over i found the girl in
the black and lit up oh she hit her
there though
she juliana she's got a good straight
there there there there we go that's
what she's there we go that's what she
wants right now that's what julianna
wants she might even pull guard yeah
that's good it's me mario
oh there's tony hinchcliffe if you see
him where no i think he has uh yeah oh
that is him yeah he's a true religion
shirt they broke him up oh it runs over
all right oh and that's uh what's his
name uh is it
dude opens yeah who's tony he's good i
like him he's a nice dude
if he doesn't kill you he's a comic
really good comic yeah
um he moved off dude she's been dropped
three times yeah look at this though if
he goes to disneyland
oh my
remember how she god she was she's
watching this oh she was out there no
she wouldn't wouldn't hurt her i think
she was she was throwing a jab on she's
crazy yeah
she never lost eye contact
but i tell you what dude she's what's
she thinking right now [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
nothing's working [ __ ] yeah you know
what coach is thinking
[ __ ] yeah hey listen hey you got to get
a hold of her yeah i don't like the guy
in the back
the answer right now
she's using her creeps on you what you
got to do is you got to move okay the
creeps come in doesn't matter you see
your legs open you got to back up
the answer is hey you got to do the job
you've got to get her to the wall you
have to get her to the wall you have to
get her down you got a grapple yeah quit
striking yeah it's not our night yeah
you can't you can't go look at her
smiling yeah trouble yeah
you can give her [ __ ] uh things at
crystallia.com you see that
get it let's get her to the wall and get
her down yeah i don't care if you jump
guard do everything you can [ __ ] dive
at her legs
chris you know what she would do we
should pay a ufc fighter to have a
mouthpiece that says life rips oh that
would be hilarious yep oh that'd be cool
yeah there you go [ __ ] they're so broke
if i do it for free just give them a
mouthpiece i'm paying five g's to do it
oh for sure
have on break we'll make it
does not break this going around i don't
even know i'm kidding me would that be
worth your point i guess it would be
worth it oh
oh what the [ __ ] happened there
um
i know that uh
i had a fight where my mouthpiece
allowed four times so i'm not a good guy
to ask about mouthpiece
[ __ ] sorry gotta watch that off the old
vet sterilization my mouth [ __ ] guard
fell out i gotta look for it i can't
find it anywhere and then
hold on i was in my anus the whole time
look that was such a soft entrance you
see that [ __ ] gosh she's not yeah that's
like going in on a chick you're not that
interested in just [ __ ] limping in
there wow that was not wow
you're better than that
you're better than that
[ __ ] amanda nunes
brazilian bull yeah dude she's all about
her like i mean i understand you're
worried about her power but you can't
[ __ ] you can't half step a shot you
gotta go in on it yeah she's like half
entry there yeah who are you talking
about the other one yeah julian pena
good girl in all black
the champion which is crazy yeah that's
the champ see look see how they're
playing paddy kick right there so what
what what julianna payne is doing is
falling for this this bit that that uh
put her hand up there she's taking her
out of her total game now look get your
[ __ ] chin she throws punches like
ronda rousey did remember that one video
yes that shoot those punches like that
i have a song my [ __ ] head like
you're saying this that's not good huh
keep your chin down yeah no don't you
don't have your chin up hands down chin
up
yeah i mean but juliana has good
pressure though like she's going forward
okay grapple now here's the you can't
grab a broom or a man nunez also a black
belt on the ground
amanda nunez
right yeah that is right there you go
get off me that's for you get off me
thank you she's like get off she's a
black belt and it's also yeah i'm sure
she's no [ __ ] party down there i mean
like it's going to be annoying as [ __ ]
but you're saying payne is a better uh
grappler pen is a damn good grappler
penny has a better chance to finish the
fight
but not from the bottom but not from
bottom there's a lot of brazilians that
are that are black belts that aren't
like real active black belts yeah and
especially their guard yeah yeah
chris is a what are you a purple chris
uh yeah uh in japanese no i blue bell in
brazilian
i did japanese first i didn't know what
it was
it was [ __ ] no i am japanese no i'm
saying you know
oh no i did it but i didn't know this
was [ __ ] before even the ufc was a
big thing oh so
[Music]
which is rare and you know how flexible
chicks are dude they can get their foot
in anywhere man yeah texas
right stupid hey right though that's my
size right if they queef no i'm not
saying if they did it would go into the
other one
you're so [ __ ] science is that
science yeah you i'm saying you know
what you sound like you know you're
having sex i'm going with a guy and
you're
doing him and you
and he farts you burp that you know what
it means
[Laughter]
can you google that can you
google that please you sound like you
know what you're talking about so i'm
buying something i'm buying it mm-hmm
oh she got opened up she's like
dude
you don't hear anything and you just
keep burping like how many times has
juliana bled in the fight
i i haven't eaten are you i wonder
because if she hasn't bled much this
might change her because that's gonna
believe me i don't think so she's oh
she's gonna drink what's that on the
planet
go go plot as her kick her down keep the
reason no no it's too loose it's too
loose too loose you could read it
there's a reversal
kick up to a triangle they don't look
loose to me these guys look very tight
no
oh look at the blood wow i thought she
was gonna bite her that's what i'm
saying it's it's a different thing
seeing your own blood come out yeah so
like it can it can either make it turn
into an animal or it can break it real
quick well i don't know hey that was a
tattoo
i'm broken okay
you know what i mean i don't want to see
i don't think i would shave my armpits
if i was a chick
one time one time i was ufc fighting i
would always run around the ring that's
right when i got in i remember running
around and the fight performer was
really bloody and i ran around i stepped
in warm blood and in my head i went what
the [ __ ] am i doing
that's hilarious
oh what happened that's a good fight
well he was right
for sure
uh it might be three right in that third
round i think the second round was it
yeah yeah that was the second round
oh
yeah so much my second round for albania
everybody
man
yeah julian pena yeah did she she woke
up that brazilian [ __ ] bull man she
brought out the goat yeah because and i
i'll be honest i picked july to win this
fight but you said also third fourth
fifth round if she could survive the
first game yes i said but again but i
was assuming amanda came out she don't
want to be in there came out like a band
she's just to hurry it up but amanda's
been calculated she wants to be in there
she's smiling she's lighting her up
she's beating her on the ground
she's coming
oh man
is he getting taken down
oh there's a killer team
too man
those cookies are sweating though it's a
little wet right good it looked like it
was melting
didn't know good notice i just ate it
it's
like how an elbow can be both a razor
blade and a sledgehammer it depends on
which part you use man yeah it barely
grazes it's a [ __ ] you're [ __ ] cut
so bad we can barely graze this i'll be
in dallas
christie.com savannah georgia as well
atlanta i mean just crazy washington dc
you're looking at that lawnmower 4.0
dude shave your eyebrows hey listen if
you use that lawnmower 410 does it catch
your balls and cut them well that's the
best that's the thing about them that's
[ __ ] great i do my anus
i have
it has a light on it too my anus
yeah guys guys guys it's dark i got this
it's like a one of those flood lights
like a miner's hat
with that high-pitched squeal
yeah somebody turn on the lights no i
got it it's a fourth one that was the
third round chin i'm right yep oh damn
we're good wow that went fast
you just you know what you do you just
pull your dick
and turns the light on and on your butt
but you gotta go dry say we need to go
docking
sorry tell them
what we're talking about sorry that's
good listen you're good bro
listen i have some bad tattoos but i i
really want to know why she had the
super mario dad but hey everybody's got
a story stupid
yes no well yeah it might be fourth
round the fifth is gonna get dicey i
julian opening is so [ __ ] tough i bet
it goes all five but i could see this
ending in the fifth although we're only
one minute into the [ __ ] fourth round
and she's getting beaten molly it's cool
oh she's got good posture oh look at
that
oh it's the third time she's gone no no
it's too late she grabbed the inside of
her leg and pulled back in
listen to me telling grappling positions
don't worry about me i got this covered
but so i mean if i could end just like
that right you get in one of these like
grappling things trying to get in the
hole
oh yeah
anderson silva yeah chad was whipping
his ass just like this uh not santa boys
but they're both good at grappling yeah
difference jail was really bad jiu jitsu
yeah you talked to chill ever oh yeah i
[ __ ] love you you got to hassle
[Applause]
oh she got it she's lucky oh she didn't
oh she needs to go the other way lucky
that wall's there
oh oh she gots it oh no no
that makes me so anxious that's the
worst too you just try that and you're
like god
you're [ __ ] exhausted oh right are
you better so oompa and lady and she put
all the effort into that armbar and now
she's tired and you know she had to
unhook on the near side too but she kind
of said that i want credit for it
i don't do the joke and i didn't do
it he kind of did though no i kind of
let you know i sidestepped around that
joke
he just took his red wings and flew
right through him
oh come on
took a lot of effort yeah and she has a
super mario tattoo
mario's bloody right now yeah mario's
bleeding he's something from mario
dude a movie i love this kid super mario
bros good movie dangerous little head
like what's up oh armbar
oh she has her neck
i got way too excited yeah bro i'm so
sorry it's okay man you you know we
appreciate that we're passionate yeah
and that much passion eric this is dude
i really love it right
now a word in
17 minutes i'm just falling in love this
is what happened this is like look at
this yeah this is what it is this is the
best fight oh she took her down pretty
good yeah yeah it was good she's tired
they got to end this man
slow it down fancy pants
dude i saw the picture of your [ __ ]
peach eye so this is like i don't know
what's gonna be right now we're gonna
talk about you bring up that sore
subject right now
i saw that cantaloupe
wow
throwing heat on your knuckles now
tit for ted i get what's going on here
because you get you worked on side jobs
the carpet cleaner
[Laughter]
we're all hoping eric takes home that
razor right there they had you at the
supermarket you know so people were like
they were going to just cuckoo they
would face uh
no you pick one and his face is exposed
he's like hey oh my god you said
uppercut
what a uppercut
juliana threw a jab she sat down through
a right uppercut oh
is it cut on the top of the head yeah
yeah it can run yeah yeah there's
probably a couple of them though right
i
mean
you're the husband
that you're watching this [ __ ] yeah
imagine you're the dad that's why i
never let my face imagine calvin's
fighting in this right now i would jump
in i would throw the [ __ ] talon
at three years old he's fighting i've
seen it before
yeah um well [ __ ] uh nate diaz threw a
towel in for nick diaz we'll fight
all the way around
really really yeah nick threw it in for
that josh thompson yeah yep yep yeah
that's the one we're talking about his
team
that was the hype right no i know that
and that was right but he was working
with him because he's cornering you guys
you guys have towels ready to yeah yeah
yeah so i i we josh barnett who's like a
legend like a legend
the cornerman before he'd go on he'd go
let me die in there do not touch that
[ __ ] towel and i told barnett was on
the show i go this is the difference
between you and i so i do stand up now i
would turn him go listen as soon as i
get a little bit of trouble you take
that yeah yeah [ __ ] thoughts no no
this way i said i got [ __ ] when i'm
going in give me the towel i'll use it
if i need it yeah
my shorts would have been a towel yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i saw a kid tap on a cage when they
closed the door
yeah it's not for you my man
ooh head butt oh it's a headbutt huh ow
and the back of the neck here oh she
dropped oh that that that wobbled her
huh yeah medulla blancada dude look at
that face oh she's ready to go
well that's a good cut
cool looking oh look at her that's part
of me so dog
i like that [ __ ] man i wish guys would
do that didn't you guys do that you guys
didn't do that i didn't know that
wouldn't even touch [ __ ] gloves with
me nope
[ __ ] rude see animal over there yeah
animal you know what i mean
that's me and my peaches over here
[ __ ]
south oh
she ducked in for a shot it looked like
she got it you know what by the way if
you fight again you have to come out to
justin bieber's peaches
[Music]
how's the the justin bieber's uh i get
my pizzas out in georgia yeah
oh goodness but it's the wrong size god
i want her to win
look at this
no no she out
that um
it's just not happening she's trying is
that her signature
there's
move
no
oh
my god i want her to win no it's so bad
but it's not because there's so much dog
in here so much dog oh
blood
anaconda look at that blood pass out oh
no there's an anaconda choke coming in
hot oh it's there it's knees it's i mean
the blood bro look at him in the smile
yeah she's facing ripping bro yeah no
pouring in yeah
the faucet is on
this is insane bro oof this is too much
this is a hell of a fight yeah yeah
there's crabbing there's a hell of a dog
this is the best one i've seen while i
was here i agree
ever ever this is an [ __ ] forever
this isn't
this is an ass whoop no but but there's
a lot of dog in there there's a lot of
dogs she in her ass with though i mean
she's tough as [ __ ] first team all tough
but she this ain't competitive
yeah i would have to agree to that yeah
ah interesting and i have money on the
girl on pena yes because
don't get caught very cool don't get
caught in that
twist
i don't want to get opened up even more
i thought this would start when i start
feeling bad i wish they wouldn't allow
elbows on the ground wait chris didn't
you do the campaign with me when glover
and [ __ ] yuri fought the light
heavyweight championship people think
that's like top five grass fights of all
time though
does chris remember
oh yeah that one was [ __ ] good you
just didn't you know
i was just getting an ice bath after
this you know what i mean oh thank god
i've never had a
this one and let me be totally honest
that
fight
like
with you this is fights i don't want did
i say no these take years off your life
yeah
i've had one fight like with crow cop is
similar i was inside i didn't see this
one because i did a lot of drugs i
didn't see that one with you guys yeah
you didn't do that
one yeah i don't want that one at all
after all this brawling and she gets a
submission to win too that'd just be
like talk about domination oh if the
yellow yeah while she finishes her it's
too many tough to finish pena she's such
a dog
she's from spokane she's from spokane
washington i feel like they're going to
just that's crazy i'll be in dallas
august 26th
has she ever been to baltimore spokane
spokane near dallas
[Laughter]
geographically speaking it's just as a
crow flights you know yeah speaking of
places i'm going to be in oh where la
jolla is really you know september 9th
to the 11th you know is uh la jolla next
year
now though you have time to get to
tell me that was great a bloody mess
sick yeah i'm surprised she hasn't
passed out all the blood she's lost man
oh he don't even realize that christ
well right then yeah i'm sure but that i
just want to highlight i think the
moment of the show is when eric educated
us on cows being pregnant to milk yeah
i'm pretty impressed it was pretty good
you remember how confident i was there
yeah you just were an oh [ __ ] a naysayer
yeah oh god maybe she took it easy on
her didn't want to throw that punch
she's like she's pretty the mall yeah
she knows she's one to fight right she
gotta have to get stitches no she's
trying to finish her because she's a
[ __ ] goat
and she took her title
i think uh man nunes probably retire
after well it's one and one yeah oh
there you go that's it amanda is gonna
go i'm gonna do one more to make the
money tapping her out with under a
minute left dude that's unbelievable bro
she's no she uh she's on the side really
she earns more fans yeah because she was
[ __ ] and now amanda's not going to
retire because it's 1-1 and she's so
dominant she's like i'll do that again
make a payday then oh yeah so you get
one what's their pay what do you think
their payday is on seven dollars uh
champs get a million dollars they get
[ __ ]
some burgers seven dollars oh they get
free super mario tattoos oh god yeah
that
everything yeah i wouldn't mind a yoshi
tattoo to be honest well that's bad um
she's like i beat you you know look at
her smiling because she knows i beat you
she was like i [ __ ] i beat that [ __ ]
you know what you know what's tough
about this one for julian opinion she
got out [ __ ] she got crushed she got
crushed every single round dominant like
literally almost every minute there's
two or three ten eight rounds yeah yeah
and i'm not very lucy goose through ten
eight and that guy's here is awful yeah
dude yeah
the way you added it she got [ __ ] up
that's tough
yeah that's gonna be very hard for her
to come back mentally because she got
[ __ ] if you watch this tape your team
right next week right we're rematches in
three months
what do we do what do we do pillow to
post buddy what do you do yeah she beat
up on the feet
she needs
exponentially better sparring partners
stand up wise
if that
passes her there's not enough time well
obviously i mean she's got her habits
now if that if that passes for her
training partners then she needs better
training partners or whatever vitor
belfor was on you know you feel me yeah
yeah yeah
that was tough yeah that was an [ __ ]
i was talking yeah bellefore
uh vitor back in the day was so juicy
yeah yeah but it's crazy though it's so
obvious everybody
right and you know what those were the
good years i know i was like baseball
when i saw vitor belfort for first time
i was like holy you thought it was a
stingray fighting a tan sting right now
he had no just known actors that's
hilarious a brown stingray bring it up
yeah i'm such a fan of that
[ __ ] viewer
no mohawk v tour bums me out the guy on
the left i'll jack after that mohawk
victor was [ __ ] phenomenal right
god that punch that's gonna be the the
punishment for women look at that oh
look at her eyes she went out yeah
that's what i was saying yeah she went
out she was fine i'm like no her eyes
were did you see it your eyes were like
a camille i didn't see it they were all
over the place i was looking at vitoria
from 12. yeah he's hot dude vtor 2012
whoa
2017. 2017
clearly went through chemo therapy right
no that's a good looking dude what is he
on the right yeah
bro dude look at the left the sting rate
on the left the 10. that's too much for
the sun kissing around the line i like
more of a real guy
and how do you think yeah 2012 yeah
probably is juiciest
that's that's what he was juicing yeah
oh phenomenal but he [ __ ] up bisping's
eye that's why bismuth went blind oh my
god
traumatized your poor little girl like
this he kicked him in the eye wheel
kicked him in the [ __ ] eye and lost
his eye i don't know if i'd want oh god
how do you carry that around and biz
being still won the title of that and
fought for like five or six seven years
he then took a
yeah this little girl
what would you do if your wife called
you like chris calvin's punching the
screen talking [ __ ] to that little girl
now after watching one ufc god
that's [ __ ] a lot
i
i don't know if i like that chris what
would you do if calvin wanted to fight
the ufc send him you you look at that
[ __ ] cut you want to live with look
at that goat's vagina up there good god
that's good that's open huh that is
[ __ ]
serious yeah she's gonna have to go hey
dude that's that's i guarantee you
that's at least 60 stitches she's gotta
have a concussion or something too man
oh yeah no doubt right no doubt at least
60 stitches
hey matt have you been knocked out and
uh not you can't sleep never
i've never been knocked out i've been
knocked down really
yeah that's probably true you've never
been knocked out cold you've had
concussions though probably yeah but you
know
you never had it with all your like
there was nights where i had fights
win or lose when i was concussed i
couldn't even look at my phone the light
from the i couldn't text really
concussed i couldn't text and the light
would hurt my eyes oh i thought i'd be
in a dark room for
weeks chris really
for a week
um i never had that i had time where i
was just so i had so much adrenaline
that i couldn't sleep like i like
sleeping for like two or three days
afterwards was difficult
wow um
but i never had like never pissed blood
couldn't start your phone suicidal
thoughts no nothing
never you know
hey big george let us know uh what
amanda nunes says here i guarantee you
can do one more because such an easy
fight for us she thinks
you know it's a unanimous decision too
do you think they're ever going to just
outright ban all social media in america
yes they're going to be like it's
[ __ ] destroying the fact that the
kids are committing suicide yeah way too
much it's not good but there's too much
money involved i don't know the
government you know i hate to be that
guy
no they're not going to ban social media
dude it's it's just very distracting oh
i agree i agree it's it's it's not a
positive thing oh no no yeah it's just
too much i mean what good what good
comes from it
genuinely and if it's following tickets
if there's truth on this side or truth
on that side both sides get banned right
like whatever you talk about right
in the suicide rate like if you want to
help kids
oh for sure i mean i don't know what you
do well you know i i was i was somebody
was saying i can't remember who it was
like three dads they were you know they
were talking about though they said that
the the most dangerous addiction in the
world right now is not opiates it's not
it's not weed it's [ __ ] attention
the most dangerous addiction in the
world is attention now meaning that
everybody's [ __ ] addicted to clicks
likes uh wants referrals views viral
blah blah blah everyone the attention
that's all it is well this morning or
all these thirsty [ __ ] that wear a
[ __ ] thong and try to jump on
trampolines okay let's celebrate that be
cool all right let's not get rid of that
don't be don't this isn't russia okay um
i like that but um think about this when
you turned 16 your parents bought you a
car
you weren't competing you like you were
competing with the neighborhood or
whatever high school you went to for
your car it was a dope car now you're
getting like a 97 every one paula you
were just happy to have wheels back in
my day
in the early 2000s now you're looking at
[ __ ] you know the kardashians or
whoever and they get these g wagons
you're like well my car [ __ ] sucks
dude yeah so you're competing with the
[ __ ]
kardashians well you know they say they
say comparison is the thief of uh of
happiness yeah
who said that
his name was vetrion probably john
lennon or something and that that was
good and then chris is well your thing
was um
give somebody for you
for you forgive for yourself not for
them yeah yeah yeah and he also said
something about a queef i can't remember
their legs or something this is
a theodore said comparison is the thief
of joy as appearance we must believe him
and his and keep this quote oh god suck
it you know uh it's interesting although
i'm looking at some of these tweets and
stuff and it's like the people that are
obviously very into the fight are really
respect what the other fighter survives
that's why i said she she gained more
fans by not getting submitted or
finished that's cool yes yeah yeah and
not quitting it when she had that we
were naked
that's what it was like it was [ __ ]
35 seconds left in the fight you got
smoked
in time
maybe because i'm such a penny fan i
knew she wasn't gonna quit yeah i expect
that out of her
george is she saying third fight all day
every day
and she wants to go back to brazil to
rest for a little bit so she's not
chomping at the bit oh then she also
said she met the cow that wasn't
pregnant
you know she really got me in the third
round with that queef in brazil they do
all that
i breathed it in
i don't think champ champs are good for
the sport
really i don't think at all i think
champ champs are actually a major
detriment because it ties up two
different weight classes yeah that's the
thing it ties them up ties up two
different weight classes and and it
limits the amount of people you can pub
let me tell them so so if so if you're a
champion at 145 pounds you jump to 55
you don't give up your 45 pound belt you
just jump to 55 so 45's in this
holding pattern yeah until you go back
to it
so it [ __ ] everything up ah this poor
girl man [ __ ] so how do you remedy that
the ufc promotes and that the the
biggest stars are double champ so
everyone wants to do it because the ufc
celebrates it like that you're you're on
the face of the video game you're
selling [ __ ] shorts or t-shirts where
the [ __ ] they're trying to push
to me it doesn't make sense man and then
and then if
that division properly correct because
all you did was promote her
yeah it put you in the spot man
they're kids white huh
probably from uh china
um
don't be chinese
that's her wife yes yeah she's she
fights too yeah she's she still was or
is i don't know was yeah it is it's cute
oh that's probably tough to have your
moms be ufc fighters and then you just
come home and you're like a girly girl
you're just kind of like oh i had a
thing today they they're like
you [ __ ] be your ass
mom i broke your nose shut up yeah
[ __ ] nail
look at my [ __ ] forehead i fought
four dudes today wow she grows up and
people like why are you so masculine she
was like i was raised by two moms
what are you talking about you go well
these are my moms yeah oh there's
somebody whispered they were champions
in my eye yeah 19 in this upper eye you
had 19 19 stitches
uh one of the guys you can tell if i
lift it i think it's this one yeah yeah
i've never got stitches what the [ __ ] oh
no you've never been knocked out bro
never did you ever get cut never
i was so [ __ ] happy frustrated i was
so happy didn't lose a tooth or anything
never yeah never so what his ears are
okay did you even fight
[Laughter]
eric has to catch a spot go catch eric
the [ __ ] hilarious he's at la jolla
comedy store when he's september 9th
10th 11th and i will be in baltimore
next week thursday friday saturday and
then on the 26th one show only downtown
chicago denton theater then on the 27th
i have the tough mudder go to
toughmutter.com right now august 27
chicago tough mudder sign up for the
thick mudder and use promo code team
brennan run with your boy here matt did
it last time okay
did finish um
used prone code team branding save 10
off and there's limited capacity too
many people sign up and you complain
because you don't run with me so they're
making it a smaller group so everybody
who signs up can run with me that's
august 27th tough mudder chicago and i'm
in appleton wisconsin september 8th
ontario september 15th 17th
i close september in boston but
baltimore you're up next chris is in
dallas i won't shut up about it i got a
hollywood uh improv uh uh julian friends
yeah 17th and then uh grand prairie
texas dallas uh august 26th wichita
kansas oh cool they're on the screen
atlanta georgia oh nice there you go um
keep going go go go move move
it
atlanta washington d.c stockton
california oakland california peoria
illinois rockford illinois raleigh in
north carolina savannah georgia denver
colorado cheyenne wyoming boston
massachusetts boston massachusetts
that's too the boss loves your boy
albany albany new york lakeland florida
for some reason and also jacksonville
florida for some reason i'll see you
guys there crystalia.com all right kids
we love you la hoya
you